ah hahaha
four three two one
boom thank you thanks for doing this man
really appreciate it hey welcome it's
very good to meet you
nice to meet you too thanks for not
lighting this place on fire you're
welcome
later how does one um just in the middle
of doing all the things you do
uh create cars uh rockets
all this stuff you're doing constantly
innovating decide to just
make a flamethrower where do you have
the time for that
well the family i wouldn't put we didn't
put a lot of time into the flamethrower
the this was an off-the-cuff thing and
um
so we have sort of like it's sort of a
sort of a hobby company
called the boring company uh which
started out as a joke and we decided to
make it real
and and dig a tunnel under la and then
then people other people asked us to
take tunnels and so we
said yes in a few cases and then we have
a merchandise section
that only has one piece of merchandise
at a time
and we started off with a cap and there
was only one thing on
it was just boringcompany.com cap
or hat that's it and and then we sold
the hats limited limited edition
it just said the boring company and then
i'm big fan of space balls the movie and
in space balls
yogurt goes through the merchandising
section
and they have a flamethrower in the
merchandising section
of spaceballs and
like the kids love that one uh that's
the line
when he pulls out the flamethrower it's
like we should do a flamethrower
so we does anybody tell you no does
anybody go elon
um maybe for yourself
but selling a flamethrower the
liabilities all the
people you're selling this device to
what kind of unhinged
people are going to be buying a
flamethrower in the first place do we
really want to connect ourselves
to all these potential arsonists yeah
it's a terrible idea
terrible i shouldn't buy one i don't i
said don't buy this plane thrower don't
buy it
don't buy it that's what i said but
still people bought it
yeah there's nothing i can do to staff
them it's building
i said don't buy it it's a bad idea how
many did you make
it's dangerous it's got it's wrong
don't buy it still people bought it i
just couldn't stop them
how many did you make 20 000
and they're all gone in three i think
four days
but it's sold out in four days are you
going to do a
a another run no no that's it
yes i said we'll do 20 we did 50 000
50 000 hats um
and and um that was a million dollars
and it's like okay we'll we'll sell
something and for 10 million
and that was 20 000 flamethrowers at 500
each
they went fast
how do you have the time to do that
though i mean i understand that it's not
a big deal
in terms of all the other things you do
but how do you have time to do anything
i just i don't understand your time
management skills
i i mean i didn't spend much time on on
this flamethrower i mean to be totally
frank
it's actually just a roofing torch with
an air rifle cover
it's not a real flamethrower which is
why it says not a flamethrower
that's why we were very clear this is
not actually a flamethrower
and and also we're told uh that various
countries would
would ban shipping of it but they would
not they would ban
flamethrowers so we very to solve this
problem
for all the customs agencies we labeled
it not at flamethrower
did it work is it effective i i i don't
know i think so yeah so far
yes now but you said you cannot serve a
flamethrower
but you do so many different things
forget about the flamethrower like how
do you do all that
other [ __ ] like how do you how do you
how does one decide
to fix la traffic by drilling holes in
the ground
and who do you even approach with that
like when you have this idea
who do you talk to about that i mean i'm
not saying it's going to be successful
or so
you know it's like asserting that it's
going to be successful
but so far i've lived in la for
16 years and the traffic has always been
terrible
and so i don't see any other like
ideas for improving the traffic
so in desperation we're going to take a
tunnel and maybe that tunnel will be
successful
and maybe it won't
i'm i'm listening yeah i'm not trying to
convince you it's going to work
and are the people or anyone but you're
you're starting this though this is
actually a project you're starting to
implement right yeah i know we've dug um
about a mile it's quite long it takes a
long time to walk it
yeah now when you're doing this what is
the ultimate plan the ultimate plan is
to have these
in major cities and anywhere there's
mass congestion and just try it out in
la first
yeah it's it's in l.a because uh i
mostly live in l.a
that's the reason it's a terrible place
to dig tunnels
this is one of the worst places to dig
tunnels because the
there's mostly because of the paperwork
people think it's like what about
seismic it's like
actually earth tunnels are very safe in
earthquakes
why is that earthquakes are
earthquakes are essentially a surface
phenomenon it's like like waves on the
ocean
so if there's a storm you want to be on
the
on in a submarine so being in a tunnel
is like being a submarine
now the way the tunnel is constructed is
it's constructed out of these
interlocking segments kind of like a
snake
it's sort of like a snake exoskeleton
with double seals and so
even when the ground moves the it's able
to the tunnel actually is able to shift
along with the ground like an
underground snake
and it doesn't crack or break or or and
and it's extremely unlikely that both
seals would be broken
and it's it's it's capable of taking
five atmospheres of pressure
it's waterproof methane proof or gas
proof of any kind
and uh meets all california seismic
requirements
so when you have this idea who do you
bring this to
i'm not sure what you mean by that well
when you you're you're implementing it
so you're digging holes in the ground
like you have to bring it to someone
that lets you do it yeah so
um there were there were some engineers
from spacex
um who were who thought it would be cool
to do this
uh and the guy who runs it like
day-to-day
steve davis he's a long-time spacex
engineer
is great um so
steve was like i'd like to help make
this happen i was like cool
um so we started off with
digging a hole in the ground it's got
like a permit for a pit
big pit and just dug a big pit and you
have to tell them what the pit's for or
you just say hey we just want to dig a
hole
nice fill out this form that's it
yeah i was put in our parking lot and
but do you have to give them some sort
of a blueprint for your ultimate idea
and do they have to approve it like how
does that work now we just started off
with a pit
okay big pit and um
now you know it's not really you know
don't really
care about the existential nature of a
pit you just say like i don't want a bit
right yeah and uh it's a hole in the
ground
so then we got the permit for the pit
and we dug the pit and
we dug in like i don't know three days
two three days
actually i think two 48 hours something
like that um
because uh eric garcetti was coming by
for the hype to he was going to attend
the hyperloop competition
which is like a student competition we
have for uh who can make the fastest pod
in the hyperloop
and uh he was coming this was good the
finals were going to be on sunday
afternoon
and so eric was coming by on sunday
afternoon was like you know we should
take this pit and then like show eric
uh so we was like friday morning
and then yeah so it was about a little
over 40 hours 40 hours later we dug the
pit
it was like when 24 7 or 24
48 straight hours something like that
and dug this big pit
and and and we're like showed eric the
pit
like obviously it's just a pit
but hey it's hole in the ground is
better than no hole in the ground
and what do you tell me about this pit i
mean you said this is the beginning of
this idea
yes we're going to build tunnels under
la to help funnel traffic better
and there you go and they just go okay
that but that
we've joked around about this in the
podcast before that like what other
person
can go to the people that run the city
and go hey uh we're gonna dig some holes
on the ground and put some tunnels in
there
and they go oh yeah okay now they know
where they're holding the ground but
it's uh
people think holes in the ground all the
time but my my question is like
i know how much time you must be
spending on your tesla factory
i know how much time you must be
spending on spacex
and yet you still have time to dig holes
under the ground in la and come up with
these ideas and then implement them like
i got a million ideas i'm sure you did
no shortage of that
yeah i just don't know how you manage
your time i don't understand it it
doesn't seem
it doesn't even seem humanly possible
you know i i do basically i think people
like don't
totally understand what i do with my
time
they think like i'm a business guy or
something like that
um like my wikipedia page says business
magnate what would you call yourself
a business magnet can someone please
change my wikipedia page to magnet
they'll change it right now it's
probably already changed it's locked so
somebody has to be able to unlock it and
change it to magnets
i want to be a magnet
no i i do engineering and
you know and manufacturing and that kind
of thing that's like 80 percent
more of my time ideas and then the
implementation of those ideas
that's like hardcore engineering like
yeah designing
things you know right
structural mechanical electrical
software
uh user interface engineering
aerospace engineering but you must
understand there's not a whole lot of
human beings like you you know that
right
you're an oddity yes to chimps like me
we're all chimps yeah we are we're one
notch we're not above a chimp
some of us are a little more confused
when i watch you doing all these things
i'm like how
does this [ __ ] have all this
time and all this energy
and all these ideas and then people just
let them do these things
because i'm an alien that's what i've
speculated yes
i'm on record saying this in the past i
wonder
it's true if there was one i was like if
there was like maybe an intelligent
being that we created you know like some
ai
creature that's uh superior to people
maybe just hang around with us for a
little while like you've been doing
and then fix a bunch of [ __ ] maybe
that's the way
i might have some mutation or something
like that you might do you think you do
probably do you wonder like you're
around normal people you're like hmm
like what's up with these boring dumb
[ __ ] ever
not bad for a human but i
i think we will not be able to hold a
candle to ai
hmm you scare the [ __ ] out of me when
you talk about ai between you and sam
harris i don't even
consider it until at a podcast with sam
once
right he made me [ __ ] my pants talking
about ai i realized like oh well this is
a genie that once it's out of the bottle
you're never getting it back in
that's true there was a video that you
tweeted
about one of those boston dynamic robots
and you're like in the future it'll be
moving so fast you can't see it without
a strobe light yeah
you could probably do that right now and
no one's really uh
paying attention too much other than
people like you or people that are
really obsessed with technology
all these things are happening and these
robots are
did you see the one where peta put out a
statement that you shouldn't kick robots
it's probably not wise for retribution
their memory is very good i bet it's
really good it's really good i bet it is
yes and getting better every day it's
really good are you
honestly legitimately concerned about
this are you is like ai
one of your main worries in regards to
the future
yes it it's less of a worry than it used
to be
mostly due to taking more of a
fatalistic attitude
[Music]
so you used to have more hope and you
gave up some of it and now you don't
worry as much about ai you're like
this is just what it is
yeah pretty much yes yes
but no it's not necessarily bad
it's just it's definitely going to be
outside of human control
not necessarily bad right yeah it's not
it's not necessarily bad it's just
it's just outside of human control now
the thing that's going to be tricky
here is that it's going to be very
tempting to use ai as a weapon
it's going to be very tempting in fact
it will be used as a weapon
so the the on the the on ramp to
serious ai the danger is
going to be more humans using it against
each other i think
most likely that'll be the danger
yeah how far do you think we are from
something
that can make its own mind up whether or
not something's ethically or morally
correct
or whether or not it wants to do
something or whether or not it wants to
improve itself
or whether or not it wants to protect
itself from people
or from other ai how far away we some
from something that's really truly
sentient
well i mean you could argue that any
group of people like it like a company
is essentially a cybernetic collective
of people and machines that's what a
company is
and then there are different
there's different levels of complexity
in the way these companies are formed
and then there are sort of there's this
like a collective
ai in in the google sort of search
google search you know the where we're
all sort of plugged in as like
like nerds on the network like leaves on
a big tree
or and we're all feeding this network
without questions
and answers we're all collectively
programming
the ai and the and google plus
the older humans that connect to it are
one giant
cybernetic collective this is also true
of facebook
and twitter and instagram and all these
social networks
they're giant cybernetic collectives
humans and electronics all interfacing
and constantly now constantly connected
yes constantly
one of the things that i've been
thinking about a lot over the last few
years is that
one of the things that drives a lot of
people crazy is how
how many people are obsessed with
materialism and getting the latest
greatest thing
and i wonder how much of that is
well a lot of it is most certainly
fueling technology and innovation
it almost seems like it's built into us
it's like what we like and what we want
that we're fueling this thing that's
constantly around us all the time and
it doesn't seem possible that people are
going to pump the brakes it doesn't seem
possible
at this stage we're constantly expecting
a new cell phone the latest tesla update
the newest macbook pro everything has to
be newer and better
and that's going to lead to some
incredible point and it seems like it's
built into us
it almost seems like it's an instinct
that we we're working towards this that
we like it
our job just like the ants build the ant
hill our job is to somehow rather fuel
this
yes um i mean i made this comment some
some years ago but it feels like we are
the biological bootloader
for ai effectively we are building it
and then we're building progressively
greater intelligence and the percentage
of intelligence that is not human
is increasing and eventually
we will represent a very small
percentage of intelligence
but the the ai isn't formed strangely by
the human limbic system
it is in large part our id writ large
how so we mention all those things the
sort of primal drives um
there's all all the things that
we like and hate
and fear they're all there on the
internet
their projection of our limbic system
[Music]
that's true no it makes sense and the
thinking of it as a
i mean think of thinking of corporations
and just thinking of just human beings
communicating online through these
social media networks is some sort of an
organism that's a
it's a cyborg it's a it's a combination
it's a combination of electronics and
biology yeah
this is in some measure like it's the
success of these
online systems is the is a is sort of a
function of
of how much limbic resonance they're
able to achieve
with people the more limited resonance
the more engagement um
whereas like one of the reasons why
probably instagram
is more enticing than twitter olympic
resonance yeah
you get more images more video yes
tweaking your system more yes do you
worry about
or wonder in fact about what the next
step is
i mean a lot of people didn't see
twitter coming that you know communicate
with 140 characters or 280 now
would be a thing that people would be
interested in
like it's gonna excel it's gonna become
more connected to us right
yes things are getting more and more
connected they're at this point
constrained by bandwidth
our input output is slow particularly
output
output got worse with thumbs you know we
just have
input with 10 10 fingers now we have
thumbs but
images are just are also are there a way
of communicating
at high bandwidth you take pictures and
you send pictures to people
what sends that's that communicates far
more information than you can
communicate with your thumbs
so what happened with you where you
decided or you
took on a more fatalistic attitude like
what was there any specific thing or was
it just the inevitability of our future
i try to convince people to slow down
slow down ai
to regulate ai
this was futile i tried for years
this scene nobody's seen in a movie
robots are gonna [ __ ] take over and
you're freaking me out
nobody listened nobody listens no one
are people more inclined to listen today
it seems like an issue that's brought up
more often over the last few years
than it was maybe five ten years ago it
seemed like science fiction
maybe they will so far they haven't
i think people don't like the normally
the way that regulations work
it's very slow it's very slow indeed
so
usually it'll be something some new
technology
it will cause damage or death
there will be an outcry there will be an
investigation
years will pass there will be
some sort of insight committee there
will be rule making
then there will be oversight eventually
regulations
this all takes many years this is the
normal course of things if you look at
say
automotive regulations how long did it
take for seat belts
to be to be implemented to be required
you know the water industry fought seat
belts i think for more than a decade
successfully fought any regulations on
seat belts even though
the numbers were extremely obvious if
you had a seatbelt
on you would be far less likely to die
or be seriously injured it was
unequivocal
and the industry fought this for years
successfully
eventually after many many people died
regulators insisted on seat belts
this is a this time frame is not
relevant to ai
you can't take 10 years from the point
which is dangerous
it's too late
and you feel like this is decades away
or years away from being too late if you
have this fatalistic attitude
and you feel like it's going we're in a
almost like a doomsday countdown it's
not necessarily a doomsday countdown
it's
it's a out of control countdown out of
control
yeah people call it the singularity
and uh that's that's probably thing
about it is it's a singular it's hard to
predict
like a black hole what what happens past
the event horizon
right so once it's implemented it's very
different because it
it once it's out of the bottle what's
going to happen and it will be able to
improve
itself yes that's where it gets spooky
right the idea that it can
do thousands of years of innovation very
very quickly
yeah and then we'll be just ridiculous
ridiculous we will be like this
ridiculous biological [ __ ] pissing
thing
trying to stop the gods no stop we like
we like living with a finite lifespan
and watching
you know norman rockwell paintings
it could be terrible and it could be
great it's not clear
right but one thing is for sure we will
not control it
do you think that it's likely that we
will merge
somehow or another with this sort of
technology
and it'll augment what we are now or do
you think it will
replace us
well that's the scenario the the emerge
scenario
with ai is the one that seems
like probably the best like for us yes
like if you if you can't beat it join it
that's yeah you know
um so
from a long-term existential standpoint
that's like the
purpose of neural link is to
create a high bandwidth interface to the
brain
such that we can be symbolic with ai
because we have a bandwidth problem you
just can't communicate through your
fingers is too slow
and where is neural link at right now
i think we'll have something interesting
to announce in a few months
that's at least an order of magnitude
better than anything else
probably i think better than probably if
anyone thinks is possible how much can
you talk about that right now
i don't want to drop the gun on that um
but what's like the ultimate
what's what's the idea behind it like
what are you trying to accomplish with
it
like what would you like best case
scenario i think best case scenario we
effectively emerge with ai where
we ais serves as a tertiary
cognition layer uh where we've got the
limbic system
kind of the primitive brain essentially
you've got the cortex
so you're currently in a symbiotic
relationship
with your cortex and limbic system are
in a symbolic relationship and
generally people like their cortex and
they like the olympic system i haven't
met anyone
who wants to delete their limbic system
or delete their cortex
everybody seems to like both
and the cortex is mostly in service to
the limbic system
people may think that that that they're
that they're thinking part of themselves
is in charge but it's mostly their
limbic system that's in charge
and the cortex is trying to make the
limbic system happy
that's what most of that computing power
is oriented towards
how can i make the limbic system happy
that's what i was trying to do
now if we do have a third layer which is
the ai extension of yourself
that is also symbiotic and there's
enough bandwidth between the cortex and
the ai extension of yourself
such that the ai doesn't de facto
separate
then that could be a good outcome that
could be quite a positive outcome for
the future
so instead of replacing us it will
radically change our capabilities
yes it will
enable anyone who wants to have
superhuman
cognition
anyone who wants this is not a matter of
earning power because your earning power
would be
vastly greater after you do it so it's
just like
anyone who wants can just do it in
theory
that's the theory and and if that's the
case
then and let's say
billions of people do it then the
outcome for humanity will be
the sum of
of human will the sum of billions
of people's desire for the future
billions of people with enhanced
cognitive ability
radically enhanced yes and which would
be
it how much different than people today
like if you if you had to
explain it to a person
who didn't really understand what you
were saying how much different are you
talking about
when you say radically improve like what
do you mean
you mean mind reading difficult it will
be difficult to to really appreciate
the difference um
it's kind of like how much smarter are
you with a phone or computer than
without
it's your vastly smarter actually
you know you can answer any question if
you connect to the internet
you can answer any question pretty much
instantly any calculation
that your phone's memory is essentially
perfect uh you can remember flawlessly
your phone can remember
videos pictures and everything
perfectly that's the that your phone is
already
an extension of you you're already a
cyborg
you don't even well most people realize
they are already a cyborg
it that phone is an extension of
yourself
it's just that the the data rate
the rate at which of the communication
rate between you
and the cybernetic extension of yourself
that is your phone
and computer is slow it's very slow
and and that that it's like a tiny straw
of of information flow between your
biological self
and your digital self and we need to
make that tiny straw
like a giant river huge
high bandwidth interface it's an
interface problem
data rate problem solve the data rate
problem
then i think i think we can hang on to
human machine symbiosis through the long
term
and then people may decide that they
want to retain their biological self or
not
i think they'll probably choose to
retain their biological self versus
some sort of ray kurzweil scenario where
they download themselves into a computer
you will be essentially snapshotted into
a computer at any time if your
biological self dies you could just
probably just
upload into a new unit literally
pass that whiskey we're getting crazy
over here
this is getting ridiculous down the
rabbit hole grab that sucker
give me some of that this is too freaky
see if i've been thinking about this for
a long time by the way i believe you
have
if i was talking to one cheers by the
way cheers hey this is a great whiskey
thank you i know where this came from
who brought this to us trying to
remember somebody gave it to us old camp
whoever it was thanks
yeah it is good um this is just
inevitable again
going back to your when you decided to
have this fatalistic
viewpoint so you weren't you tried to
warn people you talked about this
pretty extensively i've read several
interviews where you talked about this
and then you just sort of just said okay
it just is
let's just and you in a way you're
by communicating the potential fear i
mean
for sure you're you're getting the
warning out to some people
yeah yeah i mean i
i was really going on
the warning quite quite a lot i was
warning everyone i could even met with
obama and
just for one reason like just talk about
ai
yes and what did he say so what about
hillary
worry about her first shh everybody
crying no
he listened he suddenly listened um
i met with congress i met with
i was at a meeting of all 50 governors
and talked about just ai danger
and i talked to everyone i could
no one seemed to realize where this was
going
is it that or do they just assume that
someone smarter than them has already
taken care of it
because when people hear about something
like ai it's almost abstract
it's almost it's almost like it's so
it's so hard to wrap your head around it
by the time it already happens
it'll be too late yeah
i think they didn't quite
understand it or didn't think it was
near term or
not sure what to do about it when i said
like you know an obvious thing to do is
to just
establish a committee
government committee to gain insight you
know before
before you oversight before you do make
regulations they should
try to understand what's going on and
then
if you have a insight committee then
once they learn what's going on get up
to speed then they can make
maybe some rules or propose some rules
and and that would be probably a safer
way to go about things
it seems i mean i know that it's
probably something that the government's
supposed to handle
but it seems like i wouldn't want the i
don't want the government to handle this
who do you want to i want you to handle
it oh geez yeah i feel like you're the
one who could ring the bell better
because if if mike pence starts talking
about hey i'm like shut up [ __ ] you
don't know anything about ai
come on man he doesn't know what he's
talking about but i don't have the power
to regulate
other companies what am i supposed to do
right but maybe companies could agree
maybe there could be some sort of a
there's
we have agreements where you're not
supposed to dump toxic waste into the
ocean you're not supposed to
do certain things that could be terribly
damaging even though they'd be
profitable maybe this is one of those
things maybe you should realize that you
can't hit the switch on something that's
going to be able to think for
itself and make up its own mind as to
whether or not it wants to survive or
not
and whether or not it thinks you're a
threat
and whether or not it thinks you're
useless like why do i keep this
dumb finite life form alive
why why keep this thing around it's just
stupid it just keeps polluting
everything it's [ __ ] everywhere it
goes
lighting everything on fire and shooting
each other why would i keep this stupid
thing alive
because sometimes it makes good music
you know sometimes it makes great movies
sometimes it makes beautiful
art and sometimes you know sometimes
it's cool to hang out with
like yeah all those reasons yeah for us
those are great reasons
yes but for anything objective standing
outside like oh this is definitely a
flawed system
this is like if you went to the jungle
and you watch these chimps engage in
warfare and beat each other
with music they're [ __ ] really mean
[ __ ] mean they're real meaning i saw
that movie chimpanzee yeah i thought it
was gonna be like some disney things
like holy
cow what movie was that it's literally
called chimpanzee
is it a documentary yeah yeah it's kind
of like a documentary i was like
damn these chimps are mean they're mean
yeah they're cruel yeah they're they're
they're calculated
yeah yeah they sneak up on each other
and like i didn't realize chimps did
calculated cruelty mm-hmm yeah that's
pretty
ah i left that meeting kind of thinking
whoa this is dark
right well we know better because we've
advanced but
if we hadn't we'd be like man i don't
want to [ __ ] live in a house i like
the chimp ways bro chimp ways to go
this is it man chimp life
i know but we in a way to the ai
might be like those chimps i'm like
these stupid [ __ ]
launching missiles out of drones and
shooting each other under water
like we're crazy we got torpedoes and
submarines and [ __ ]
airplanes that drop nuclear bombs
indiscriminately on cities
we're [ __ ]
yeah they might go why are they doing
this it might like look at our politics
look at what we do in terms of our our
food system
what what kind of food we force down
each other's throats
and they might go these people are crazy
they don't even look out for themselves
i don't know i mean how much do we think
about chimps not much very little
it's like these terms are at war
these like little it's like groups of
chimps just
attack each other and they kill each
other
and they torture each other that's
pretty bad um they hunt monkeys
uh they're but like this is probably the
most
that's you know i mean when's the last
time you talk about chimps
me yeah all the time you do talking to
them okay
[ __ ] podcast dude
okay people are laughing right now
yeah constantly i'm obsessed i saw that
david attenborough documentary
on champs where they were eating those
columbus monkeys and ripping them apart
i saw that many many years ago it just
changed how i go oh
this is why people are so crazy we came
from that thing yeah
exactly yeah and there's the yeah they
got
like better philosophy yeah they're like
swingers yeah yeah they really are
they're they they seem to be way more
even than us way more civilized
they just seem to resolve everything
with sex yeah the only rules they have
is the mom
won't bang the sun that's it okay that's
it mom won't bring her sons
they're good women yeah good women in
the bonobo community everybody else just
banging it out
yeah i haven't seen the bonovo movie
[Laughter]
well they're disturbing just at a zoo
you know you have bonobos at the zoo
they're just constantly going
constantly [ __ ] yeah that's all they
do they just won't stop yeah and they
don't care
gay straight whatever let's just up
these labels
i haven't seen bonobos out of zero it's
probably like nothing nothing not in the
pg section
yeah i don't think they have them at
many zoos we've looked at it before it's
probably pretty awkward
i think that's the thing they like to
keep regular chimps at zoos because
bonobos are just always jacking off
yeah what's that they're in san diego
san diego's got some yet really
interesting
probably separate them yeah i mean how
many are in a cage you know it's like
right it's gonna be pretty intense yeah
yeah
yeah we're we're a weird thing you know
and i've often wondered if
whether or not we're you know our
ultimate goal is to give birth
to some new thing and that's why we're
so obsessed with technology
because it's not like this technology is
really i mean it's certainly enhancing
our lives to
in a certain way but is
i mean ultimately is it making people
happier right now
most technology i would say no in fact
you and i were talking about
social media before this about just not
having
instagram on your phone and not dealing
you feel better yes i think
that one of the issues with social media
that's been pointed out by many people
is that
i think maybe particularly instagram um
people look like they have a much better
life
than they really do right so by design
yeah people are posting pictures of when
they're really happy
they're modifying those pictures to be
better looking
even if they're not modifying the
pictures they're at least selecting the
pictures for the best lighting the best
angle
so people basically seem uh
they're way better looking than they
basically really are right
um and they're way happier seeming
than they really are so if you look at
everyone on instagram you might think
man they're all these happy beautiful
people
and i'm not that good looking and i'm
not happy
so i'm a suck you know and that's gonna
make feel sad so when in fact
those people you think are super happy
actually not that happy
some of them are really depressed
they're very sad
some of the happiest seeming people
actually some of the saddest people in
reality
um and and nobody looks good all the
time doesn't matter who you are
no it's not even something you should
want
why do you want to look great all the
time yeah exactly so
uh so i think i think things like that
can make people quite sad
just by comparison because you you sort
of you people people generally
think of themselves relative to to
others
it's it's a we are constantly
re-re-baselining our expectations
um and you can see this say if you watch
some show like naked and afraid or
you know if you just go and try living
in the woods by yourself for a while
and you're like the learned civilization
is quite great
it has a lot it's a lot of it it's
people want to come back civilization
pretty fast on the good and afraid
wasn't that a thoreau quote the
comparison is a thief of joy
yeah well if happiness is reality minus
expectations
that's great too but the comparison is a
thief of joy really holds true to people
is it theodore roosevelt roosevelt
fascinating
um and when you're thinking about
instagram because what essentially
instagram is with a lot of people is
you're giving them the opportunity to be
their own pr
agent and they always go towards the
glamorous
you know and when any anybody does show
you know hashtag no filter
i don't know if they really do do that
like oh you're so brave look at you
no makeup you know yeah they look good
anyway you look great what are you doing
oh my god you don't have makeup on you
still look hot as [ __ ] you know what
you're doing
i know what you're doing too they're
they're they're letting you know
and then they're feeding off that
comment section
sitting there like like it's a fresh
stream of love like you're getting right
up to the source as it comes out of the
earth and you're sucking that's a lot of
a lot of emojis
emojis emojis yeah a lot of emojis
my my concern is not so much what
instagram
is is that i didn't think that people
had the
need for this or the expectation for
some sort of technology that allows them
to constantly get
love and adulation from strangers and
comments and and this
ability to project this sort of
distorted version of who you really are
but i worry about where it goes like
what's the next one what's the next one
like where is it is it going to be
augmented to some sort of a weird
augmented or virtual
sort of instagram type situation where
you're not going to want
to live in this real world you're going
to want to interface with this
sort of world that you've created
through your social media page
some next level thing yeah
go live in the simulation yeah i mean in
the simulation some ready player one
type
[ __ ] that's real that seems we have that
htc vive here and
i've only done it a couple times quite
honestly because it kind of freaks me
out sure
my kids [ __ ] love it man they love it
they love playing these weirdo games and
and walking around with that headset on
but part of me watching them do it goes
wow i wonder if this is like the
precursor
just sort of like if you look at that
that phone that gordon gekko had on the
beach
yeah big cell phone yeah you compare
that to like a galaxy note 9.
how the [ __ ] did that become that right
and i wonder when i see this htc vive
i'm like
what is that thing going to be 10 years
from now when we're making fun of what
it is now
what is it how i mean how ingrained
and how how how connected and
interconnected
is this technology going to be in our
life
it will be at some point
indistinguishable from reality where
we'll lose this
we lose this like you and i are just
looking at each other through our eyes i
see
where you see me i think i hope you
think so i think you probably have a
regular eyes
this could be some simulation it could
do you entertain that
well the argument for the simulation i
think is quite strong
because if you assume any improvements
at all
over time any improvement one percent
point one percent just extend the time
frame make it a thousand years
a million years the universe is 13.8
billion years old
what would a civilization if you counted
if you're very generous
civilization is maybe seven or eight
thousand years old
if you count it from the first writing
this is nothing
this is nothing
so if you assume any rate of improvement
at all then
games will be indistinguishable from
reality
or civilization will end one of those
two things will occur
therefore we are most likely in a
simulation or
we're on our way to one right well just
because we exist
we could most certainly be on the road
we could be on the road to that
right it doesn't mean that it has to be
reality it could be in base reality we
could be
here now on our way to the road
or on our way to the destination where
this can never happen again
where we are completely ingrained in
some sort of an artificial technology or
some sort of a symbiotic relationship
with
the internet or the next level of
sharing information
but right now we're not there yet that's
possible too right it's possible that a
simulation is
one day going to be inevitable that
we're going to have something that's
indistinguishable from regular reality
but maybe we're not there yet that's
also possible
so we're not quite there yet that this
is real
when i touch that it feels very real
maybe that's why everybody's like into
like mason jars and [ __ ]
amazing suede shoes people are going to
like craft restaurants and
they want raw wood everyone says
everyone wants to see metal
people it seems like people are like
longing towards some weird
log cabin type nostalgia reality yeah
like holding on like
clinging just dragging their nails
through the mud like don't take me yet
yes but then but then people go get a
mason jar with a wine stem
or a handle that's dark
makes me lose faith in humanity wine
stem and a handle they have those yes
oh those dirty people that's just
[ __ ] that's like people make pet
rocks rough
right some people are just [ __ ] they
take advantage of our
our generous nature it was made with a
wine stem
made with a handle they made it that way
yes
so the the it wasn't like well on to the
mason ah that would be fine if there was
they glued it on or something right
white trash chic oh this is disgusting
look at this it is right there
yep this is terrible
yeah that's like fake breasts that are
designed to be hard like fake breasts
from the 60s
it's like if you really along for the
ones with ripples here we go
yeah that's almost what that is yeah
what are you going to do man there's not
nothing you know something you do stop
certain terrible ideas from propagating
yeah um
anyway i don't sound like things are too
dark because i think like
you kind of have to
be optimistic about the future there's
no point in being
pessimistic it's just too negative
it doesn't help you know i think you
want to be
i mean my theory is like you'd rather be
optimistic
i think i'd rather be optimistic and
wrong than pessimistic and right
right at least or on that side right
yeah
because if you're pessimistic it's going
to be miserable
yeah yeah nobody wants to be around you
anyway if it's the end of the world
you're like i
told you bro yeah the world's ending
yeah it is what it is for all i mean
enjoy the journey right if you really
want to get morose i mean it is
what it is for all of us anyway we're
all going to go unless some
something changes yeah i mean ultimately
you know even if we just sort of existed
as humans forever we'd be
would still eventually be like the heat
death of the universe right a zillion
years from now
right even if we get it past the sun if
we figure out a way past the sun
running out of juice eventually it's
going to end it's just a question of
when
right so it really is all about the
journey hmm
or transcendence from whatever we are
now
into something that doesn't worry about
death
the universe as we know it will
dissipate
into a fine mist of
cold nothingness eventually and then
someone's going to bottle it and put a
fragrance to it
sell it to french people in another
dimension
it's just a very long time so i think
it's really just about
how can we make it last longer are you
a proponent of the multi-universes
theory do you believe that there are
many many universes and that even if
this one
fades out that there's other ones that
are starting fresh right now and there's
an infinite number of them
and they're just constantly in this
never-ending cycle of birth and death
i think most likely this is just about
probability there
are many many simulations
these simulations are you might as well
call them reality
or you could call them multiverse these
simulations you believe are created
like someone has manufactured running on
the substrate
so that substrate is probably boring
boring
how so well when we create a simulation
like a game or a movie it's a
distillation of what's interesting about
life
you know it takes take a year to shoot
an action movie
and then that's all to slow down into
two or three hours
so let me tell you if you see an action
movie being filmed it's freaking it's
boring
super boring it takes there's like
lots of takes there's everything's in a
green screen
looks pretty goofy doesn't look cool but
once you add the cgi
and have great editing it's amazing
so i think most likely
if we're a simulation it's really boring
outside the simulation
because why would you make a simulation
that's boring it makes simulation way
more interesting than the base reality
that is if this right now is a
simulation yes
and ultimately inevitably we're if as
long as we don't die or get hit by a
meteor
we're going to create some sort of
simulation if we continue on the same
technological path where
we're on right now yes but we might not
be there yet
so it might not be a simulation here
but it most likely is you feel other
places
this notion of place or where is is
a flawed yes flawed
like that if you have this sort of
that uh vive you know
which that's made by valve and
st and it's really valve that made it
htc did the hardware but it's really a
valve thing
um makers of half-life yes
wow great company great company um
uh when you're in the
in that some in that your virtual
reality
which is only going to get better where
are you where are you really
right you aren't anywhere well where is
the computer
what what you know what defines where
you are exactly right it's your
perception
is it your perceptions or is it you know
a scale that we have under your butt
you're right here i've measured you
you're the same weight as you were when
you left
but you meanwhile you're experiencing
why do you think you're where you are
right now
you might not be i'll spark up a joint
if you keep talking
your manager's gonna come in here we
might have to lock the door
right now you think you're in a studio
in l.a that's what i heard you might be
in a computer oh listen man i think
about this all the time
yeah i mean it's unquestionable that one
day that'll be the case
as long as we keep going as long as
nothing interrupts us
and if we start from scratch and
you know we're single-celled organisms
all over again and then
millions and millions of years later we
become the next thing that is us
with creativity and the ability to
change its environment it's going to
keep monkeying with things
until it figures out a way to change
reality
to change i mean to almost like punch a
hole through
what is this thing into what
what it wants it to be and create new
things and then
those new things will intersect with
other people's new things and it'll be
this
ultimate pathway of infinite ideas
and expression all through technology
yeah and then we're one we're gonna
wonder
like why are we here what are we doing
let's find out well
i i mean i think we should take the
actions
the set of actions that are most likely
to make the future better
yes right yeah right right
and then we evaluate those actions to
make sure they're they're that
it's true well i think there's a
movement to that i mean in terms of like
a social movement
i think some of it's misguided and some
of it's exaggerated and there's a lot of
a lot of people that are fighting for
their side out there but it seems like
the general trend of like uh
social awareness seems to be much more
heightened now
than has ever been in any other time in
history because of our ability
to express ourselves instantaneously to
each other through
facebook or twitter or what have you and
that the trend is
to uh abandon preconceived
notions abandon prejudice abandon
discrimination
and promote kindness and happiness as
much as possible
look at this knife somebody gave it to
me sorry yeah what is this the [ __ ] did
you do
my friend donny he brought this with him
and it just stayed here
i have a real samurai sword if you want
to play with that i know you're into
weapons that's from the 1500s
samurai at the end of the table yeah
that's cool i'll grab it hold on
yeah that's a legit samurai sword
from an actual samurai from the 1500s
if you pull out that blade that blade
was made the old way
where a master craftsman folded that
metal and hammered it down
over and over again over a long period
of time and honed that blade into what
it is now
what's crazy is that more than 500 years
later
that thing is still pristine i mean
whoever
took care of that and passed it down to
the next person who took care of it and
you know until it got to the podcast
room it's pretty [ __ ] crazy
yeah one day someone's going to be
looking at a tesla like that
these [ __ ] back doors they pop up
sideways
like a lamborghini
you should see what tesla can do uh you
didn't
you should i'll show you afterwards well
i've driven one i love them yeah but
most people don't know what it can do
in terms of like ludicrous mode in terms
of driving super fast and irresponsibly
on public roads is that what we're
saying
well any call can do that yeah what can
it do that
that i need to know about i mean the
model x can do this like ballet thing
to the trans-siberian orchestra it's
pretty cool where it dances
yes legitimately moves around
why would you program that into a car
seemed like fun that's what i get about
you that's what's
weird like when you showed up here you
were all smiles and you pull out a
[ __ ] blow torch and not a blow torch
but i'm like look at this dude a
flamethrower not a flamethrower like you
want to be clear it's definitely not
playing you're having fun like this is
uh
like this thing when you know you
program a
car to do a ballet dance it's very fun
how do you have the time to do that i
don't understand why you're digging
holes under the earth and centered
rockets into space
and and powering people in australia
like how the [ __ ] do you have time to
make the car dance ballet
well i mean in that case
there were some engineers at tesla that
said you know what if we
make this car dance and play music
i was like that sounds great please do
it
let's try to get it done in time for
christmas we did is there a concern
about someone
just losing their mind and making it do
that on the highway
no it won't do that what if it's in
bumper-to-bumper traffic
nope no won't do it nope it's actually
you have to it's an easter egg oh it's
an easter egg yeah that's why people
don't know about it
including people have the car well it's
like it can do lots of things lots of
things
once reddit gets a hold of it everyone's
oh you just have to
it's everyone if you search for it on
the internet you will find out but
people don't know that
they should even search for it oh well
they do now
yes yes there's so many things about the
model x
and the model s and the model 3 that
people don't know about we should
probably do a video or something
and explain it because i have close
friends of mine and i say do you know
the call can do this and they're like
nope do you want to do a video though do
you like the fact that
some people don't know no i think it's
probably not
we should tell people yeah probably yes
that would help your product
i mean it's not like you don't sell
enough of them you sell almost too many
of them
right the
i mean i think a tesla
is the most fun thing you could possibly
buy ever
that's what it's meant to be well our
goal is to make
it's it's not exactly a car
it's actually a thing to maximize
enjoyment
electronic like big screen laptop
ridiculous speed handling all that stuff
yeah do you you have going to put video
games in it
you are yeah is that wise well
you won't be able to drive while you're
playing the video game
but we're like for example we just we're
just putting the the atari emulator raw
emulator in it
so you'll be able to play missile
command and lunar lander and a bunch of
other things
yeah that sounds cool it's pretty fun i
like that yeah and we improved the
interface and missile command because
it's too hard with the old trackball
so this is this is a touchscreen version
of missile command
so you have a chance
[Laughter]
do you you have an old car don't you
don't you have like an old jaguar
yeah how do you know that that's that's
what another uh
61 series one e-type jaguar i love cars
it's great
yeah i love old cars that's one of the
only
yeah the only two got only two gasoline
cars i have of that
and an old like a ford model t
that a friend of mine gave me that's
those are only two gasoline cars
is the ford model t all stock well oh
there's your car
ooh look i have the convertible that is
a cool
car god that's a good looking car
yes is that yours that is
it's not mine it's extremely close to
mine that i don't have a friend's
license plate on mine
oh it's a beautiful car they nailed it
that's that's mine looks like that
god they nailed that that's what mine
looks like
maybe that is mine there's certain
iconic shapes
yes and there's there's something about
those cars too they're not as capable
not nearly as capable as like a tesla
but there's something
really satisfying about the mechanical
aspect of like feeling the steering and
the
grinding of the gears and the shifting
there's something about those that's
extremely satisfying even though they're
not that competent
like i have a 1993 porsche
964 it's like a lightweight
it's not it's in the rs america it's not
very fast it's not like in comparison to
a tesla or anything like that
but the thing about it is like it's
mechanical
you feel it everything's like
it's like it gives you this weird thrill
like you're on this
clinky ride and there's all this
feedback
there's something to that yeah yeah
absolutely i mean
yeah my e-type is like basically no
electronics
yeah um you like that but you also like
electronics
yes like your tesla is supe it's like
the far
end of electronics yes
drives itself it's driving itself better
every day
yeah it's like we're about to release
the software that
will enable you to just turn it on and
it'll drive from highway on-ramp to
highway exit do lane changes
to overtake other cars jesus go from one
interchange to the next if you get on
say the 405 and get on get off 300 miles
later and go through several highway
interchanges and just
overtake other cars and hook into the
nav system
and then uh and you're just meditating
home
yeah your car's just traveling very it's
kind of eerie
it's kind of eerie what did you think
when you saw that video that dude
falling asleep behind the wheel
i'm sure you've seen it the one in san
francisco he's like right outside of san
jose dudes out cold like this
and the car is in bumper to bumper
traffic moving along yeah
have you seen it right yeah yeah we
changed the software we changed the
software
that's i think an old video we changed
software if if you don't touch the wheel
it will gradually slow down and put the
emergency lights on
and wake you up oh that's hilarious yeah
that's hilarious
yeah can you choose what voice wakes you
up well it's sort of more of a
it sort of honks oh it honks this should
be like wake up [ __ ] face
well you're endangering your fellow
humans we could we could gently wake you
up with a sultry voice
ah that would be good like uh something
with a southern accent
hey why can't we wake up sunshine hey
sweetie
exactly why don't you wake up you're
like pick you could pick your
right like what do you want yeah i
choose the australian girl for siri yeah
i like her voice do you want to seduce
my favorite
i like australian what flavor of do you
want to be angry could be anything
you want those australian prison lady
jeans now when you
um when you program something like that
in is this in response to
a concern or is it your own yeah if you
do you look at it and go hey
um they shouldn't just be able to fall
asleep let's wake them up
yeah yeah we it's like you know we're
like well
you know people are just falling asleep
we're about to do something about that
right but when you first released it you
didn't consider it right you're just
like well
no one's gonna just sleep people fall
asleep in
cars all the time all the time and crash
yeah at least our car doesn't crash
that's better
it's better not to crash imagine if that
guy had fallen asleep in a in a gasoline
car they do it
all the time for sure yeah they would
crash into somebody yeah
and in fact the thing that really you
know
got me to it's like man we better get
autopilot going get it out there
it was a guy was in an early tesla
driving down the highway and he fell
asleep and he ran over a cyclist and
killed him
and it's like i was like man if we had
autopilot
wouldn't run out of one we might have
fallen asleep but at least he wouldn't
run over that cyclist
so how did you implement it like did you
just use cameras
and yeah programmed with the the system
so that if it sees images
it slows down and how much time do you
give
is the person who's in control of it
allowed to program how fast it goes
yes yeah you can program it to be more
or less
like more conservative like more
aggressive driver
um and you can say what speed you want
it to
what what speed is okay i know you have
ludicrous mode do you have douchebag
mode
well it just cuts people off well
for lane changes it's tricky because if
you're in like
la like unless you're pretty aggressive
right it's pretty it's hard to change
lanes
it's hard to be sat nam it's hard to be
namaste
out here in l.a yeah you get if you want
to hit that santa monica boulevard
off-ramp i mean you got to be a little
pushy you got to be a little pushy
yeah especially angry yeah a little
angry they don't want you in they speed
up
sometimes you know i think people like
overall are pretty nice on the highway
even in la but
sometimes they're not do you think the
neural link will help that
probably everybody be locked in together
this hive mind
tunnels will help it won't have traffic
that'll help a lot
yeah how many of those can you put in
there because thinking about traveling
buddy
nice thing about tunnels is you can go
3d so you can go
many levels right so until you hit hell
yeah but you could go you could have a
hundred levels of tunnel no bombs
jesus christ i don't want to be on 99.
that'll be the 99th
negative 99 floors whoo
this is one of the fundamental things
people don't appreciate about
tunnels is that it's not like roads the
fundamental issue with roads is that you
have a 2d
transport system and a 3d living and
workspace environment
so you got all these tall buildings or
concentrated work environments and
and then then you want to go into this
like 2d transport system which is hugely
inefficient pretty low density
because cars are spaced out pretty far
and and so that obviously is not going
to work you're going to have traffic
guaranteed
but if you can go 3d on your transport
system
then you can solve all traffic you can
either go 3d
up with a flying car or go 3d down with
tunnels
you can have as many tunnel levels as
you want and you can
arbitrarily relieve any amount of
traffic
you can go further down with tunnels
than you can go up with buildings
you're ten thousand feet down if you
want
i wouldn't recommend it but what was
that movie with uh
what's his face bradley coote not
bradley cooper
uh christian no what the [ __ ] his name
who is batman
christian bale where he they fought
dragons him and matthew mcconaughey
they went down deep into the earth how
how how deep can you go
yeah it was it was batman fought dragons
batman but it was christian
rain of fire rain of fire okay ever saw
that
no
yeah earth is a giant ball of lava
with a thin crust on the top which we
think of as like the surface
this thin crust and it's mostly just a
big bowl of lava
that's earth but ten thousand feet's not
a big deal
have you given any consideration
whatsoever to the flat earth movement
i think that's a troll situation oh it's
not
no it's not you would like to think that
because you're a super genius but i
as a normal normal person i know there's
people way dumber than me
and they really really believe they
watch youtube videos which go on
uninterrupted and spew out a bunch of
[ __ ] fake facts
very eloquently and articulately
and they really believe these people
really believe i mean if it works for
them
sure
fine fine it's weird though right that
this age
where you know there's ludicrous mode in
your car goes 1.9 seconds
0 to 60. 2.2 2.2 which one's 1.9
the road the next generation roadster
okay standard edition yeah
i'm on top of this [ __ ] that's just
that's that's what the standard edition
yeah so it's
about the performance package what
performance package
yeah what what the [ __ ] do you need to
put rocket thrusters on it
for real yes what are they to burn
nothing uh high
ultra high pressure compressed air whoa
just call gas thrusters do you have to
have air tanks or they just suck in the
air out of
okay yeah i just have electric pump whoa
pump it up to like ten thousand psi
and how fast are we talking zero to
sixteen how fast you wanna go
i'm so i'm gonna go we could make it
just fly i wanna go back in time
make it fly you make it fly sure do you
anticipate that as being i mean you were
talking about the tunnels and then
flying cars do you really think that's
going to be real
too noisy and there's too much air flow
so the fundamental issue with flying
cars
i mean if you get like one of those like
toy drones
think of how much how loud those are and
how much
air that they how much air they blow now
imagine if that's like a thousand times
heavier
this is not going to be make your
neighbors happy
your neighbors are not going to be happy
if you land a flying car in your
backyard
it will be very helicopters helicopter
or on your roof they're just really
going to be like
what the hell that was annoying yeah you
can't even like
if you want a flying car just put some
wheels on a helicopter is there a way
around that like what if they figure out
some sort of magnetic
technology like all those bob lazar type
characters were thinking that was a part
of the
ufo technology they were doing it area
51
remember didn't they have some some
thoughts about magnetics
nope no [ __ ] yes really yeah there's
a fundamental momentum exchange
with the air so you must uh
you you must accelerate you there's
there's like
there's there's a certain you have a
mass and you have gravity gravitational
acceleration
and mass mass times your mass times
gravity must equal the mass of airflow
times the acceleration of that air flow
to have a neutral force so it's
impossible
and then you won't move but if okay if
mg is greater than m a
you will go down and if ma is greater
than mg you will go up
that's how it works there's just no way
around that there is definitely no way
around it
there's no way to create some sort of a
magnetic something or another that
allows you to
technically yes you you could have
a strong enough magnet
but that magnet would be so strong
that you would create a lot of trouble
we just suck cars up into your car
just pick up i mean you'd have to rappel
off of either
material on the ground or
in a really nutty situation off of
earth's gravitational field
and somehow make that incredibly light
but that magnet would cause so much
destruction you'd be better off with a
helicopter so if there was some sort of
magnet road like you have two magnets
and they repel each other
if you had some sort of a magnet road
that was below you and you could travel
on that magnet road that would work
hahaha yes
yes you could have a magnet road a
magnet road is that too ridiculous
no it would work so you could do that
ridiculous too right i would not
recommend it
there's a lot of things i don't
recommend i would super not recommend
that
not good not wise i think no roads no
no that no definitely not
definitely it was good that would cause
a lot of trouble so you've put some time
and consideration into this other than
uh
you know instead of like my
foolishly rendered thoughts so you think
that tunnels are the way to do it
oh it'll work for sure that'll work yes
and your these
these tunnels that you're building right
now these are basically just like test
versions of this
ultimate idea that you have
you know it's just a hole in the ground
right we played videos of it
where you just your idea is that you're
going to drop that hole in the ground
there's a sled on it and the sled goes
very fast like 100 miles an hour plus
yeah you can go real fast you know fast
as you want
and then if you want to go long
distances you can just draw the air out
of the tunnel
make sure it's real straight draw the
air out of the tunnel yeah
it's a vacuum tunnel um because the
then and then depending on how fast you
want to go you need these wheels
or you could use air bearings depending
upon the ambient pressure in the tunnel
or you could
mag levitt if you want to go super fast
um so magnet road yes
but underground magnet roads underground
manual otherwise you're going to really
create a lot of trouble with because
there's metal things ah
so magnet road's the way to go just
underground if you want to go really
fast
underground you would be in you would be
maglev in a vacuum tunnel
mag in a vacuum tunnel magnetic
levitation in a vacuum tunnel
one with rocket launchers no i would not
recommend putting any
exhaust gas in the tunnel oh okay i see
what you're saying you're going to pump
it out
right you'll have to pump it out and you
probably have a limited amount of air in
the first place like how much can you
breathe
do you have to pump oxygen into these
cubicles
you'd have a pressurized pot to be like
like a little tiny underground spaceship
basically like an airplane
because you have air in the airplane
it's not getting new air in it is
it is yes they have like a little hole
yeah they have a pump
really yeah it gets it from the outside
yes wow i didn't know that it's like
it's the air is airplanes have it have
it
easy because they essentially you can
they're pretty leaky
uh but jesus yeah so long as they
as long as the air pump is working at a
decent speed they have backup pumps
oh still have like you know three pumps
or four pumps or something
and uh and then that then there's like
there's an ex
it exhausts through the outflow valve
and and through whatever seals are not
sealing quite right
usually the door doesn't seal quite
right on a plane this is a bit of
leakage around the door
and uh and but the pumps
uh exceed the outflow rate and then that
sets the pressure in the in the cabin
now have you ever looked at planes and
gone i could fix this
i just don't have time how does it make
it design for a plane
you do yes a better design
i mean probably i think it is yes
who have you talked to about this
and i've talked to friends friends
friends and
i'm your friend girlfriends you can tell
me
what do you got what's going on well i
mean the exciting thing to do would be
some sort of electric vertical takeover
landing supersonic
jet of some kind of vertical takeoff and
let it be no need for a runway just
shoot up
straight in the air and then
how would you do that when they do that
and some military aircrafts correct yes
the trick is that you have you have to
transition to level flight
um and then you the the the thing that
you'd use
for vertical tail for takeover landing
is not suitable for high-speed flight
so you have two different systems i
thought about this quite a lot
i've thought about the screen quite a
lot
the interesting thing about an electric
plane is that you want to go as high as
possible
but you need a certain energy density in
the battery pack um because you have to
overcome gravitational potential energy
once you've overcome gravitational
potential energy and you're
at at a high altitude the energy
you use in cruise is very low and then
you can recapture
a large part of your the gravitational
potential energy on the way down
so you really don't need any kind of
reserve fuel if you will because you
have the the energy of height
gravitational potential energy
this is a lot of energy so
so once you can get high at high you the
the
like the way to think about a plane is
it's a force balance
so the force balance so
a plane that is not accelerating
um is a neutral force balance
yeah the force of gravity you have the
lift force of the wings
then you've got the force of the
whatever thrusting device
the the propeller or turbine or whatever
it is
and you've got the resistance force of
the air now the higher you go
the lower the air resistance is air
density drops exponentially
but drag increases with the square an
exponential beats a square
the higher you go the faster you will go
for the same amount of energy
at a certain altitude you will you can
go supersonic
with less energy per mile quite a lot
less energy per mile
than an aircraft at 35 000 feet
because it's just a force balance
i'm too stupid for this conversation
it makes sense though no i'm sure it
does now
when you think about this new idea of of
of designing it i mean
when when you have this idea about
improving planes
are you going to bring this to somebody
or you just
chuck i have a lot on my plate right
that's what i'm saying
i don't know i don't know how you do
what you do now but if you keep coming
up with these
but it's got to be hard to pawn these
off on someone else either hey
go do a job good job with this vertical
take off and landing system that i want
to implement
to regular planes the airplane
electric airplane isn't necessary right
now electric cars
are important solar energy is important
stationary storage of energy is
important these things are much more
important than creating electric
supersonic fetal
also the planes naturally
you really want that gravitational
energy density for an aircraft
and this is improving over time so
you know it's important that we
accelerate the transition to sustainable
energy
that's why electric cars it matters
whether electric cars happen sooner or
later
you know we're really playing
the crazy game here with the atmosphere
and the oceans we're taking vast amounts
of carbon
from deep underground and putting this
putting this knee in the atmosphere this
is crazy
we should not do this it's very
dangerous
so we should we should accelerate the
transition to sustainable energy
i mean this the bizarre thing is that
obviously we're going to run out of oil
in the long term you know we're gonna
there's only so much oil we can
we can mine and burn it's total logical
we must have
such a sustainable energy transport and
energy infrastructure in the long term
so we know that's the end point we know
that so why run
this crazy experiment where we take
trillions of tons of carbon from
underground
and put it in the atmosphere and oceans
this is an insane experiment
it's the dumbest experiment in in human
history
why are we doing this it's crazy
do you think this is a product of
momentum that we started off doing this
when it was just a few engines a few
100 million gallons of fuel over the
whole world
not that big of a deal and then slowly
but surely over a century
it got out of control and now it it's
not just
our fuel but it's also
i mean fossil fuels are involved in so
many different
electronics so many different items that
people buy
there's just this constant desire for
fossil fuels constant
need for oil without consideration of
the sustainability the things like oil
oil coal
gas it's the easy money right it's easy
money so
have you heard about clean coal the
president's been tweeting about it's got
to be real
clean coal all caps did you see he used
all caps
clean coal um well
you know it's very difficult to put that
co2 back in the ground
it doesn't like being in solid form it
takes a lot of energy like that like
some sort of a filter
giant building sized filter sucks carbon
out of the atmosphere
no no it doesn't it's not possible no no
no no definitely in [ __ ]
no we're not [ __ ]
i mean this is quite a complex question
right
you know we're really just when we're
the more
carbon we take out of the ground and add
to the atmosphere
and and a lot of it gets permeated into
the oceans
the more dangerous it is like i i don't
think right
now i think we're okay right now we can
probably even add some more
but the momentum towards sustainable
energy is
too slow like the
there's a vast base of industry
vast transportation system like this
there's two and a half billion cars and
trucks in the world
so and and the the new car and truck
production if it was a hundred percent
electric
that's only about a hundred million per
year
so it would take if you could snap your
fingers
and instantly turn all
old cars and trucks electric it would
still take 25 years
to change the transport base to electric
makes sense because how long does a
truck car truck last before it
goes into the junkyard and gets crushed
about 20 to 25 years
is there a way to accelerate that
process like some sort of subsidies or
some encouragement from the government
financially
well the thing that is going on right
now is that there's a
an inherent subsidy in any oil burning
device any any power plant or car
is fundamentally uh consuming
the carbon capacity of the oceans and
atmosphere
or just say atmosphere for short so like
you can say
okay there's a certain probability of
something
bad happening past a certain carbon
concentration in the atmosphere
and so there's some uncertain number
where
if we put too much carbon in the
atmosphere things overheat
oceans warm up ice caps melt
ocean real estate becomes a lot less
valuable
something's underwater and
and but it's not clear what that number
is but it's definitely a scientist with
all
it's really quite the scientific
scientific consensus
is overwhelming um
overwhelming i mean i don't know any
serious scientists actually zero
literally zero who who don't think
that you know that that
we were have quite a serious climate
risk that we're facing
and so there's fundamentally a subsidy
occurring
with every fossil fuel burning thing
power plants aircraft
car frankly even rockets i mean rockets
use up
you know they burn they burn fuel but
there's just
you know with rockets there's just no
other way to to get to
orbit unfortunately so it's the only way
but with cars there's definitely a
better way with electric cars
and to generate the energy do so with
photovoltaics because we've got a giant
thermonuclear reactor in the sky called
the sun
it's great it shows up every day very
reliable
so if you can generate energy from solar
panels stored with batteries
you can have energy 24 hours a day
um and then you can
you know concentrate to the poles or
near
to the north uh with uh you know high
voltage lines
also the north northern part parts of
the world tend to have
a lot of hydropower as well
but anyway all fossil fuel powered
things
have an inherent subsidy which is their
consumption of the carbon capacity of
the atmosphere
and oceans so
people tend to think like why why should
electric vehicles have a subsidy
but they're not taking into account that
all
fossil fuel burning vehicles
fundamentally
are subsidized by the cost the
environmental cost
to earth
but nobody's paying for it we are going
to pay for it obviously
in the future we will pay for it it's
just not paid for now
now what is the bottleneck in regards to
electric cars and
trucks and things like that is it
battery capacity
yeah i've got to scale up production got
to make the car compelling
make it better than gasoline or diesel
cars
make it more efficient in terms of like
the distance it can travel yeah you're
going to be able to go far
far enough recharge fast and your
roadster
you're you're anticipating 600 miles is
that correct
yeah yeah what is it 600 miles is that
right now like have you driven one 600
miles now
no we could totally make one right now
that would do 600 miles but the thing is
too expensive
so it's like the car much more so
well you know just have a 200 kilowatt
hour battery pack and you can go 600
miles
what do you have now 330
mile range so that's really 30 miles
what is that in terms of kilowatts
well that would be for a model s
100 kilowatt hour pack will do about 330
miles maybe 335
but some people have hypermiled it to
500 miles
hyper mild it would yeah i just like go
on 45 miles an hour or something yeah
they're like 30 miles an hour or
something
it's like on level ground with you pump
the tires up
really well and go on a smooth surface
and and you can go for a long time
um but do you like definitely
comfortably do 300 miles
is fine for most people uh
usually 200 or 250 miles is fine 300
miles is
you don't even think about it really is
there any possibility that you could use
solar power that
solar powered one day especially in los
angeles i mean as you said about that
giant nuclear reactor a million times
bigger than earth just floating in the
sky
is it possible that one day you'll be
able to just power all these cars
just on solar power i mean we don't ever
have cloudy days
if we do there's three of them
well the surface area of a car is
without making the car like really
blocky um or having some like a g
wagon yeah like and just like having
like a lot of surfs area where like
maybe like solar panels fold out or
something
like your e-class that's what we needed
uh
the e-type yeah that the e-jaguar e-type
with a giant long hood that could be a
giant solar panel
well at the beginning of tesla i did
want to have this like unfolding solar
panel thing
that you'd press a button and it would
just like unfold these solar panels and
like charge
recharge your car in the parking lot ah
yeah we could do that but i think it's
probably better to just put that on your
roof
right and yeah and then it's going to
just be facing the sun all the time
because like what car otherwise your car
could be in the shade you know covering
the shade
in a garage or something like that yeah
didn't a fisker have that on the roof
the fiskar
karma new generation for i believe it
was
only for the the radio is that correct
yeah i mean i think it could like
recharge like two miles a day or
something did you laugh when they
started blowing up when they got hit
with water
do you remember what happened they got
the what yeah they when
they had a a dealership or oh yeah the
fisker karmas were parked
was that like that with a flood in
jersey yes yes when the
the hurricane came in they got
overwhelmed with water and they all
started exploding
this [ __ ] great video of it did you
watch the video i i didn't watch the
video but i didn't see
that picture of the ass being naked
lubed up
watched that video laughed my ass off
they all blow up
they got wet and they blew up that's not
good yeah we made our battery waterproof
so that doesn't happen
smart move yeah there's a guy in
kazakhstan that um i think it was
kazakhstan
that he he just boated through a tunnel
under an underwater tunnel
like a flooded tunnel and just
turn the wheels to steer and press the
accelerator and it just
floated through the tunnel and he's wow
steered around the other cars
you're like that's amazing it's on the
internet what happens if your car
gets a little sideways like if you're
driving in snow like what if you're
driving if your auto pilot
is on and you're in like denver and it
snows out
and your car gets a little sideways does
it correct itself
oh yeah it's got great traction control
but does it know how to like correct
do you know how like oh yeah your ass
end kicks out you know how to counter
steer
oh yeah no it's really good it knows how
to do it yeah wow
it's pretty crazy that's pretty crazy
yeah so like if you're going sideways
it knows how to correct itself it
generally won't go
sideways it won't no why not it will
correct itself before it goes sideways
even in black eyes yeah this video is
where you could see the car
be uh try it alone
traction control system is
very good it makes you feel like
superman it's great
you like you feel like you can like this
it will
make you feel like this incredible
driver i believe it yeah now how do you
program
we do our testing on like an ice lake in
sweden
oh really yeah and like norway and
canada and a few other places porsha
does a lot of that too
new zealand as well they do a lot of
their they do some of their driver
training school on these frozen surfaces
so you're just you the car's going
sideways whether you like it or not and
you have to learn how to
slide into corners and how to adjust
well electric cars have really great
traction control because the reaction
time is so fast
right so with the gasoline car you've
got a lot of latency
uh it takes a while for the and the
engine to react and for the
you know but for elec electric motors
incredibly precise
um that's why you like you can imagine
like like
if you had like a printer or something
uh
you would only you wouldn't have a
gasoline engine printer that would be
pretty weird
um or or like a surgical device it's
gonna be
an electric motor on the surgical device
on the printer
gasoline engine's gonna be just chugging
away
it's not going to have the reaction time
but to an electric motor
it's operating at the millisecond level
so
it can turn on track on and off traction
within like inches of getting on the
honest like let's say drive a patch of
ice it'll
turn traction off and then turn it on a
couple inches right after the ice
like it's a little patch of ice because
in in the frame of the electric motor
you're moving incredibly slowly you're
like a snake it's you're a snail
you're just moving so slowly
because it's it's it can see at a
thousand frames a second
and so it's say one mississippi it
it just thought about at things a
thousand times so it's realized that
your wheels are not getting traction
it understands there's some slippery
surface that you're driving on yes and
it makes adjustments
in real time yes in milliseconds
that would that would be so much safer
than a regular car yes
it is just that alone for loved ones
you'd you'd want them to be driving your
car
yes i'm on dude board
regular motors the the
s x and three are have the lowest
probability of injury of any cars
ever tested by the us government wow
this is yeah
but it's pretty funny it's pretty crazy
like we you know people still sue us
like they'll have like some accident
at 60 miles an hour where they'd like
twisted an ankle
and they sleep they like they'll be dead
in another car
they still sue us but that's to be
expected it is to be expected
do you take that into account with like
the same
sort of fatalistic uh
you know undertones just sort of just go
uh
you gotta just let it go this is what
people do tell you i've got it that's
what it is
quite a lot of respect for the justice
system judges are very smart
and they see they've like i haven't so
far i've found judges to be very good at
justice
because i like like what like
and juries are good too like they're
actually quite good
um you know people you know you read
about like occasional
errors in the justice system let me tell
you most the time they're very good
um and like you know the guy i mentioned
that
who fell asleep in the car and he he
rode over a cyclist
and you know and and that was what
encouraged me to
get autopilot out as soon as possible
that guy sued us
he sued you for falling asleep yes he
i i'm not kidding he blames it on the
new car smell
what yes he blamed him falling asleep
on your new car smell there's someone
there's a lawyer this is a real thing
somewhere there's a lawyer that thought
that through in front of his laptop
before he wrote that up
yes he got a lawyer and he sued us and
the judge was like you're
this is crazy stop bothering me no thank
god
yes thank god thank god there's a judge
out there with a brain
i'll tell you judges are judges are very
good some of them what about that
judgment
a lot of boys up up the river in
pennsylvania who is
selling those kids out you know about
that story yeah judge was
selling young boys to prisons he was
like literally yeah literally under
bribes
for he was was this an elected judge or
he was like somebody said you have a
judge that's like actually a politician
no he's elected judge this is a very
famous story
who he's in jail right now i think for
the rest of his life
and he put away he he would take like a
young boy would do something like steal
something from a store
and he would put him in detention for
you know five years something
ridiculously egregious and they
investigated his history and they found
out that he was literally being paid off
um was it by private prisons
is that what the the deal was there was
some sort of uh
but anyway this judges two judges two
judges kids for cash scandal is what
it's called
2008 yeah um common please judges
so i think they are elected and who is
paying them oh
um someone
it was proven to the point where they're
in jail now that someone was paying them
to uh put more asses in the seats in
these
private prisons a million dollar payment
to put him in the youth centers builder
a million dollar payment yeah i do think
it's this private prisons thing is
creating a bad incentive right yes
um but i mean that judge is in prison
um thank god yes but i i for people who
think perhaps the justice system
consists entirely of judges like that i
want to assure you this is not the case
the vast majority of judges are very
good i agree and
they care about justice and they could
have made a lot more money if they
wanted to be a trial lawyer
and instead they cared about justice and
they made less money because they care
about justice and that's why they're
judges
i feel that same way about police
officers i feel like there's so many
interactions with so many different
people with police officers
that the very few that stand out that
are horrific
we we tend to look at that like this is
evidence that police are all corrupt and
i think that's crazy
no most most police are are are very
honest yes um
and uh and and and and like
the military evidence military personnel
that i know are very honorable ethical
people
yes and much more ethical than the
average person that's my impression
that's my impression as well but and
that's not to suggest that we
be complacent and assume everyone's
honest and ethical
and obviously if somebody is is given a
a
trusted place in society such as being a
police officer or a judge and they are
corrupt then we must be extra vigilant
against such situations
yes and take action uh but but we should
not think that this is somehow broadly
descriptive
of people in that profession i couldn't
agree more i think there's also an issue
with um one of the things that happens
with police officers prosecutors and
and anyone that's trying to convict
someone or arrest someone
is that it becomes a game and in games
people want to win
and sometimes people cheat yes
yes i mean if you know if you're a
prosecutor
you should not always want to win there
are times when you should like okay
i just should not want to win this case
um and then
you know like just pass on that case
sometimes people want to win too much
that is true
um i think also the it becomes tough if
you're
if you're like a district attorney you
know
you you tend to sort of see a lot of
criminals and then
your your view of the world can get
negatively yes you know
have a negative you know
you have a negative view of the world
because you know you're just interacting
with a lot of criminals
but actually most of society is not
consistent criminals right
um and i actually had this conversation
at dinner several years ago with
district attorney i was like man it must
sometimes seem pretty
pretty dark because you know
man there's some some terrible human
beings out there
and he was like yep and he was like
dealing with some case
which consisted of a couple of old
ladies that would
run people over somehow for insurance
money it was rough
i was like wow that's that's that's
pretty rough
it's like it's like hard to maintain
faith in humanity if you're a district
attorney but
but you know it's only a few percent of
society that are
actually bad and then if you go to the
worst
say point one percent of society or the
worst one in a thousand one in a million
you know like how bad is the millionth
worst person in the united states
pretty damn bad like damn evil like
the the millionth like the
millionth well one in a million of evil
is
so evil people cannot even conceive of
it
but there's 330 million people in the
united states so that's 330 people
out there somewhere but by the same
token there's also
330 people who are incredible angels and
unbelievably good human beings yeah
on the other side but because of our
fear of danger
we tend to our thoughts tend to
gravitate towards the worst case
scenario
yes and we want to frame that and it's
one of the real problems with prejudice
we want whether it's prejudice towards
different minorities or prejudice
towards police officers or anything
it's like we want to look at the worst
case scenario and say this is an example
of what this is all about
and you see that even with people how
they frame genders
some some men frame women like that they
get ripped off by a few women and they
decide all women are evil
some women get [ __ ] over by a few men
all men are [ __ ] and
and this this is very toxic and it's
also
it's a very unbalanced way of viewing
the world
and it's very emotionally based and it's
based on your own experience your own
anecdotal experience
and it can it can be very influential to
the people around you
and it's just it's a dangerous way it's
a dangerous thought
process and pattern to promote it is it
is a very dangerous
pattern i really think you know people
should give other people the benefit of
the doubt
and assume that they're good until
proven otherwise
and i think really most people are
actually pretty good people
nobody's perfect they have to be if you
think of the vast numbers of
us that are just interacting with each
other with each other constantly
yeah we have to be better than we think
we are yeah there's no way like there's
no other way i mean hear all these
weapons like but how many times like
nobody's presumably trying to murder you
and you're nobody
yes nobody's like putting that's right
it's right there fake flamethrower here
it's not
not a flamethrower now we got a real
problem i'm gonna put it on that side
too i'm gonna leave it for the guests
yeah i'm like look man if i say
something that [ __ ] up it's right
there
so we'll liven things up for sure
it's guaranteed to make any party better
yeah well that's i mean that's the
armed uh civilization theory right
that a an armed uh community is a
safe and polite community yeah
texas it's kind of true yeah i mean
people in texas are super polite and
everyone's got a gun yes
don't make somebody angry yeah i don't
know don't know what's going to happen
yeah it's not a good move yeah piss
people off when everybody can have a gun
yeah off to just let that guy get in
your lane yeah
yeah uh you know we got a big uh
test site in central texas near waco oh
beautiful yeah spacex uh
in mcgregor um it's about 15 minutes
away from wake up that's close to where
ted nugent lives
shout out to ted nugent okay cool yeah
um
yeah they're you know we have luck lots
of fire and loud explosions and things
and people like that
they're cool with it they don't give a
[ __ ] out there they're very supportive
yeah that you can buy fireworks where
you know your kids go to school
yeah it's you know it's dangerous
yeah but it's free it's free there's
something about texas that's very
enticing because of that
it is dangerous but it's also free right
yeah yeah i kind of like texas actually
well
i prefer it over places that are more
restrictive
but more liberal because you could
always be
liberal like just because things are
free and just because you have a certain
amount of
you know right wing type characters it
doesn't mean you have to be that way
you know and and honestly there's a lot
of those people that are pretty [ __ ]
open-minded and let you
do whatever you want to do right you
don't bother them
yeah exactly that's my hope right now
with um the way we're able to
communicate with each other today
and how radically different it is than
generations past is that we all
just the dust settles and we all realize
like like what you were saying that
most people are good most people are
good the vast majority
yes i think you should give people the
benefit of that for sure i think you're
right
yeah you know who can help that what
mushrooms
don't you think they're delicious yeah
right
yeah they're good for you too yeah all
of them
all kinds of them um
what do you see in terms of like when
you think about the future of your
companies
what do you see as like bottlenecks you
want some more of those uh sure
thank you what do you see in terms of
like
bottlenecks of things that are that are
holding back innovation
is it regulatory commissions and and
people that don't understand the
technology that are
influencing policy like what what what
could potentially be holding
you guys back right now
is there anything that you would change
yeah that's a good question
you know i wish i wish politicians were
better at science
that would help a lot that's a problem
yes there's no incentive for them to be
good at science
there isn't um actually you know they're
pretty good at science in china
i have to say yeah the
mayor of beijing is i believe in
environmental engineering degree
and the deputy mayor as a physics degree
i met them
and uh mayor shanghai is really smart
and you're up on technology what do you
think about this government
policy of of stopping use of huawei
phones and there's there's something
about the the
the worry about spying is
i mean from what i've understand from
real tech people
they think it's horseshit
oh i like phones i don't know i don't
know
um like the government say don't you buy
huawei phones
does that do are you up on that at all
no should we just abandon this idea
well i think like i guess if you're if
you're uh
if you have like top secret stuff um
then you want to be pretty careful about
what hardware you use
uh but you know like most people do not
have top secret stuff
right and like nobody really cares what
porn you watch you know right
like it's like nobody actually cares
you know so and if they do that's kind
of on them
like national spy agencies do not care
do not
give a rat's ass what porn you watch
they do not
care so like what secrets
does a national spy agency have to learn
from the average citizen
nothing well that's the argument against
the the narrative and the argument by a
lot of these tech people is that the
real concern is that these companies
like huawei
are innovating at a radical pace and
they're trying to stop them from
integrating into our culture
and letting this like right now they're
the number two
cell phone manufacturer in the world
okay samsung's number one huawei is
number two
apple is now number three they surpassed
apple's number two
and the idea is that this is all taking
place without them
having any foothold whatsoever in
america there are no there's no
carriers that have their phones you have
to buy their phones
unlocked through some sort of a third
party and then put it okay
so and the the worry is you know that
these
are somehow another controlled by the
chinese government
the communist chinese government is
going to distribute these phones
and i don't know if it's the worries
economic influence
that they'll have too much power i don't
know what it is are you are you paying
attention on
any of this not really you know i don't
think we should worry too much about
huawei phones
uh you know maybe you know our national
security agencies shouldn't have
huawei phones maybe that's a question
mark uh
but uh i think for the average citizen
it doesn't matter
doesn't doesn't like no they're not i'm
pretty sure
the chinese government does not care
about the goings-on of
the average american citizen is there
is there a time where you
think that there will be no security
will be impossible to hold back
information that whatever bottleneck
we'll we'll let go
we're gonna we're gonna give in that
whatever bottleneck between privacy
and ultimate innovation will have to be
bridged
in order for us to achieve the next
level of technological proficiency that
we're just going to abandon it
and there'll be no no security no
privacy
do people want privacy because they seem
to put everything on the internet
well right now they're confused but when
you're talking about your neural link
and this this idea that one day
we are going to be able to share
information we're going to be some sort
of a thing
that's symbiotically create uh
symbiotically connected yeah i think we
really need to
worry about security in that situation
and for sure that's like a
security paramount sure yeah but also
what we will be
is will be so much different our
concerns about money
about status about well all these things
will seemingly go by the wayside if we
really become enlightened
if we really become artificially
enlightened by some sort of an
ai interface where we have this
symbiotic relationship
with some new
internet type connection to information
what you know what happens then
what what is important what is not
important is
privacy important when we're all gods
i mean i think the things that we think
are important to keep private right now
right we probably will not think are
shame right
information right
what do you what do you hide emotions
what are we hiding
i mean i think like i don't know maybe
it's like embarrassing stuff right
embarrassing stuff but
there's actually like i think people
there's like not that much
that's kept private that people that is
actually relevant
right that's people what other people
actually care about and we think other
people care about it but they don't
really care about it and certainly
governments don't
well some people care about it but then
it gets weird when you when it gets
exposed like jennifer lawrence when
those naked pictures of her got exposed
like i think in some ways people liked
her more they realized like
she's just a person just a girl who
likes sex
and is just alive and has a boyfriend
and sends them messages and now you get
to look into it and you probably
shouldn't of
but somebody let it go and they put it
online and all right
she seems to be doing okay she's a
person she's just you and me and it's
the same thing she's just in some weird
place where she's on a
35 foot tall screen with music playing
every time she talks
yeah i i i i mean i'm sure she's like
not
she's not happy about it but she's but
she's clearly doing fine
but once this interface is fully
realized
where we really do become something far
more
powerful in terms of our cognitive
ability or our ability to understand
irrational thoughts and
and mitigate them and that we're all
connected
in some sort of an insane way what i
mean how what our thoughts on wealth
our thoughts on social status like how
many of those just evaporate
and our need for privacy maybe our need
for privacy will be the ultimate
bottleneck that we'll have to substitute
that we'll have to surpass
i think the things that we think are
important now
will probably not be important in the
future but there will be things that are
important
what would be more different things
i know there might be some more of ideas
potentially
i don't think darwin's going away right
no one's going to be there
no one dawn will be there forever
forever
yeah it would just be a different a
different arena
different arena a digital arena
different arena
darwin's not going away
what keeps you up at night
well it's quite hard to run companies
yeah
especially car companies i have to say
it's quite challenging the car
business is the hardest one of all the
things you do yes
because it's a consumer-oriented
business as opposed to like spacex and
not that spacex spacex there's no walk
in the park
but but a car company it's very
difficult to keep a car company
alive it's very difficult you know
there's only two car companies
in the history of american car companies
that haven't gone bankrupt and that's
ford
and tesla that's it yeah ford rode out
that crazy storm huh they're the only
ones
the skin of their teeth shout out to the
mustang
yeah yeah by the skin of their teeth
that is interesting right same with
tesla we
barely survived how close did you get to
folding
very close we uh
for 2008 is not a good time to be a car
company especially a startup car company
and
especially an electric car company that
was like stupidity squared
and this is when you had those cool
roadsters with the t-top yeah with the
um
target top yeah we had like uh
he was a highly modified elise chassis
the body was all completely different
by the way that was a super dumb
strategy that we actually did
was dumb it was based on two false
premises
uh one false premise was that we'd be
able to
cheaply convert the lotus elise and use
that
as a car platform
and that we would be able to use
technology from this little company
called ac propulsion
for the electric drivetrain and the
battery
problem is the ac propulsion technology
did not work in production
and we ended up using none of it in the
long term
none of it we had to redesign everything
and then
the once you add a battery pack an
electric motor
to the car it got heavier got 30 heavier
invalidated the entire structure all the
crash structure everything had to be
redone
nothing like i think it had less than
seven percent of the parts were common
with any other device including
cars or anything that's the seven
percent
yes everything including tires and
wheels bolts
brakes yeah even the steering wheel
see the steering wheel was i think the
steering wheel was
almost the same yes the
the windscreen when it's different no i
think the windscreen is the same same
yes i think i think we were able to keep
this last seven percent so that's right
basically every body panel is different
the entire structure was different
the uh we couldn't use the h
like the hvac system the you know the
air conditioner was a belt-driven air
conditioner
so now we needed uh something that was
electrically driven we need a new
ac compressor and all that takes away
from the battery life as well right
yeah we needed a small highly efficient
air conditioning system
um that fit in a tiny car and was
electrically powered not belt driven
it was very difficult how much did those
weigh the
those cars the roadster i think it was
about twenty seven hundred pounds
that's still very sound depending on
which version twenty six fifty to twenty
seven fifty pounds something like that
and what was the weight distribution
um it was about fifty
well there were different versions of
the car um so it was about
55 on the rear because it was rear
biased right but
not bad like considering like a 911
which is like one of the most popular
sports cars of all time
heavy rear end bias well i mean
yeah the 911 i think the joke is like
they managed to
despite newton not being on their side
yeah if you're fighting newton it's very
difficult
well it's like you've got those the
moments of inertia on a 911
don't make any sense they do once you
understand them
once you understand you don't want to
hang the engine off the ass this is not
a wise move
you don't want to let up on the gas when
you're in a corner
the problem with whether with with
something that's
where the engine is mounted over the
rear axle or off the rear axle towards
the rear
is that your moment of inertia is
fundamentally screwed you cannot solve
this
it's unsolvable you're screwed
you're screwed right like essentially if
you spawn the car like a top
that's your problem moment of inertia
you're just
i promised i wouldn't swear on this show
by the way really to who
because it was my friend tell that
friend to go [ __ ] himself who told you
not to swear
afraid i'm not a good friend yes
definitely
realize you're [ __ ] elon musk you can
do whatever you want man
if you ever get confused call me i'll
swear in private
swear up a storm just say fricken it's a
fun way there's like
old house moms
[Laughter]
wives and [ __ ] that have children oh
this freaking thing
yeah but anyway like like the porsche is
kind of incredible how well porsche
handle is given
that uh it's the physics yes the moments
of inertia are
so messed up uh to actually still make
it work
well is is incredible well if you know
how to turn into the corner once you get
used to the feeling of it there's actual
benefits to it
you know there are some benefits i enjoy
i the car i had before
tesla was a 911. oh okay that was 997
or six yeah 997 yeah yeah
um great car man yeah i mean
particularly with on the porsche
when they had the variable vanes uh the
turbo and you didn't have the turbo lag
that was great
yeah that was really great the turbo lag
was is like
you know if you floor it like phone home
call your mom the older one about an
hour later the car accelerates
and super dangerous too because then the
real wheels start spinning
yeah yeah there's something fun about it
though like feeling that
rear weight kicking around you know and
again
it's quite efficient a good feel to it
yeah yeah i agree but that's that's what
i was talking about earlier about that
little car that i have the
93 911 it's just there's it's not fast
it's not it's not the best handling car
but it's more satisfying than any other
car i have
because it's so mechanical it's like
everything about it like
crackles and bumps and it gives you all
this feedback and
i take it to the comedy store because
when i get there i feel like my brain is
just popping and it's on fire
it's like a strategy for me now that i i
really stopped driving other cars there
i drive that car there just for the
brain juice
just for the the the inner the
interaction
i mean you should try model s p 100 d
i'll try to blow your mind
your skull okay yeah tell me what to
order i'll order it
model sp 100d okay jamie that's the best
car that i drive
okay okay i'll get with the car you
drive okay
it will blow your mind out of your scope
i believe you how far can i drive
how far about 300 miles that's good for
la
regular days you will never notice the
battery never
never how hard is it to get like one of
them crazy plugs
installed in your house that difficult
no it's super easy it's like
yeah it's like a dryer plug it's like a
dryer outlet didn't you come up with
some crazy
tiles for your roof that are solar
paneled yeah yeah we're i have it on my
roof right now actually
i'm just trying it out it's like it's
the thing it takes a while to like test
roof stuff because roofs have to last a
long time
right so like you want your roof to last
like 30 years
over a regular groove now so there's two
versions there's like the solar panels
you put on a roof so like depending on
whether your roof's new or old so if
your
roof's new you don't want to replace the
roof you want to put like solar panels
on the roof
right um so that's like retrofit you
know and then we're trying to make the
retrofit panels look real nice
um and then but then the new product
we're coming out with is if
you if you have a roof that's either
you're building a house or you're gonna
replace your roof anyway
then you make the site the tiles have
solar
solar cells embedded in the tiles and
then
it's quite a tricky thing because you
want to not see the solar cell behind
the
like the glass tile uh so you have to
really work with like the glass and and
the
various coatings and layers so that you
don't see the solar cell
behind the glass otherwise it doesn't
look right right
so it's really tricky there it is jamie
put it up there yeah and that looks good
see is there a uh see like if you look
closely you can
see if you're zooming like you can see
the so you can see the cell
but if you zoom out you don't see the
cell right well it looks cool though
like that's that's hard visible it's
really hard because you have to have
sunlight go through
right but where to cut when this when it
gets reflected back out
it doesn't it it hides the fact that
there's a cell there
now are those available to the consumer
right now
well we have uh i think those on that
roof right there
yes that's amazing oh that looks good
yeah oh i like that that one's hard
oh so you got that kind of fake spanish
looking thing
i like that that's french slate that's
white people in connecticut smoking
pipes
look at that one yeah that's badass dude
so those all actually work i believe you
so the the the
the solar panels that are on that house
that we just looked at is that
sufficient to power the entire home
it depends on your energy on how yeah
yeah
so um
generally yes i would say it's probably
for most
it's going to vary but anywhere from
more than you need to uh maybe
half like call it a half to 1.5 of the
energy that you need
depending on how much roof you have
relative to living space
and how ridiculous you are with the tv
tv is no problem
air conditioning air conditioning okay
air conditioning is the problem
if you have an efficient air conditioner
and you don't
and depending on how like are you air
conditioning rooms when they don't need
to be air conditioned which is very
common because it's a pain in the neck
it's like programming a vcr it's like
right you know it's just the blinking 12
and so people just like hell with that
i'm just going to make it this
temperature all day long
right you don't have a smart home where
if you're in the room then it stays cool
right
yeah it should predict when you're going
to be home
and then cool the room the rooms that
you're likely to use
with a little bit of intelligence we're
not talking about like genius home here
we're just talking like elementary
basic stuff um you know like if you
could hook that into the car
like it knows you're coming home like
there's no point in cooling the home
keeping the comb keeping the whole the
home really cool when you're not there
right but it can tell that you're coming
home it's going to cool it to the right
temperature right you have an app there
that works with your solar panels or
anything like that
yeah yeah we do and we need to hook it
into the air conditioning to really make
the air conditioning work
have you thought about creating an air
conditioning system
i know you have a trick question
cannot answer questions about future
potential okay let's just let it go
we'll move on to the next thing that
would be an interesting idea
yeah i would say radiant heating all
that
good ideas now when you when you think
about the efficiency of these homes and
you think about
implementing solar power and battery
power
and is there anything else that people
are missing is there any other like
i just saw a smart watch that is powered
by the heat of the human body
it's some new technology it's able to
fully power that way
i don't know if it's fully or if it's
like this watch right here this is a
casio
okay um it's called a uh pro-tec and
it's in like an outdoors watch and it's
solar-powered
okay and so it has the ability to
operate for a certain amount of time on
solar
yeah so if you have it exposed it could
function for a certain amount of time on
solar
yeah well you know um like there's the
self-winding watches where
you know it's just got a weight in the
watch and as you move your wrist the
weight moves from one side to the other
and it winds the watch up that's a
pretty cool thing
yeah yeah well it's amazing that like
rolex is that it's all done mechanically
there's
no batteries in there there's no nothing
yeah you could do the same thing create
a little charger that's
based on uh wrist movement it really
depends on how much energy your watch
uses
you know what's [ __ ] up about that
though we accept a certain amount of
like [ __ ] with those watches like i
brought my watch
i have a rolex that my friend lorenzo
gave me and i brought it to
um the watch store and i said this
thing's always
fast i said it's always like after a
couple months it's like five minutes
fast
and they go yep they go yeah really it's
just what it does
and i go hold on i go so you're telling
me that it just is always going to be
fast
it's like yeah it's just like every few
months you gotta like reset it
seems like they should recalibrate that
thing they can't they tried
they say every few months whether it's
four months or five months or six months
it's gonna be a couple of minutes fast
okay it seems like they should really uh
recalibrate that because if it's always
fast you can just you know delete those
minutes you need to [ __ ] kick down
the door at rolex
and go you [ __ ] are lazy
[Laughter]
it's kind of amazing that you can keep
tie mechanically on a wristwatch
with these tiny little gears it's
amazing yeah i mean the the whole
luxury watch market is fascinating i
i'm i'm not that involved in
in terms like i don't buy them i bought
them as gifts i don't buy them for
myself but when i look at them
online like there's million dollar
watches out there now that are like
they have like little rotating moons and
stars and
they they live like look at this thing
how much is that one jamie
these are [ __ ] preposterous i like
gears
i love them yeah i think they're
beautiful but there's some of these
people that are just taking it right in
the ass
they're buying these watches for like
750 000 i'm like yo that's a timex sun
nobody knows it's not any better than
some casio that you could just buy
online like look at that though well
here's the thing
if you're a person that doesn't just
want to know the time
you want craftsmanship you want some
artisans touch
you want innovation in terms of like a
person
figuring out how gears and cogs all
line up perfectly to every time it turns
over it's basically a second
i mean that's just there's there's art
to that that's it
yeah it's not just telling time i like
this watch a lot but if it got hit by a
rock i wouldn't be sad
yeah it's just a watch it's a it's a
mass-produced thing that runs on some
quartz battery
but those things that's there's art to
that no i agree
it's beautiful yeah yeah i love it yeah
there's something there's something
amazing about it it's because it
represents the human creativity it's not
just
it's not just uh electronic
innovation there's something there's
there's a person's
work in that yes but you don't have a
watch on
no ever i used to have a watch what
happened mike
my phone tells the time so good point
what if you lose your phone do you wait
hold on true let me guess
you are a no case guy
that's correct living on the edge
looking on the edge without a case tyson
neil degrasse tyson was in here last
week
i i marveled at his ability to get
through life without a case
that's right you know he takes his phone
and he flips it in between his fingers
like like a like a a a soldier would do
with his rifle
right he just rolls that [ __ ] in between
his fingers okay marvelous
wow he says that's the reason why they
do it he said will you look
at someone who has a rifle why would
they do that why would they flip it
around like that
right so that when it goes to drop they
have it in their hand
they catch it quickly so that's what he
does with his phone
he's just flipping his phone around all
the time i got that in mexico
i was hoping it holds joints does it do
anything it seems to open oh it's just
a hole just a hole good storage storage
in there but like
try to put a joint in there close it you
put like one one blunt
one but it seems pretentious
you know that's the idea behind it i
bought it
when i was in mexico because i figured
it would be a good size
to hold joints restaurant
so is that a joint
or is it a cigar no okay it's um
marijuana inside of uh tobacco okay
so it's like posh plot tobacco you never
had that yeah i think i tried one once
come on man you probably can't because
stockholders right
i mean it's legal right it's totally
legal okay
how does that work do people get upset
at you if you do certain things
there's tobacco and marijuana in there
that's all it is
the the combination of tobacco and
marijuana is wonderful
first turned onto it by charlie murphy
and then reignited by dave chappelle
there you go
plus whiskey exactly perfect
balances it out alcohol alcohol is a
drug it's been grandfathered in
well it's not just a drug it's a drug
that gets a bad rap
because you just have a little it's
great
fine yeah a little sip here and there
and you just
your inhibitions are relaxed and it
shows your true self and hopefully
you're more joyous
and friendly and happy and and
everything's good
the real worry is the people that can't
handle it like the real worry about
people who can't handle
cars that can go zero to 60 in 1.9
seconds or
anything have you ever considered
something
that like imagine if one day everyone
has
a car that's on the same at least
technological standard as one of your
cars
and everyone agrees that the smart
thing to do is not just to have bumpers
but to perhaps have some sort of a
magnetic repellent device
something some electro magnetic field
around the cars
that as cars come close to each other
they automatically radically decelerate
because of magnets or something
well i mean our cars break automatically
break yeah yeah when they see things
yes but like a physical barrier like
uh well the wheels work pretty well the
wheels do yeah yeah
they work pretty well decelerated that's
you know 1.1 to 1.2 g's that kind of
thing
is there a concern that one day all your
cars will be on the road
and then they'll still be regular people
with regular cars
20 30 years from now that'll
get in the mix and be the the main
problem
yeah i think it'd be sort of like it was
a time of transition where there were
horses
and gasoline cars on the road at the
same time it's been pretty weird
oh that'd be the weirdest yeah i mean
horses were tricky you know
back in uh manhattan had like 300 000
horses you figure like
a horse lives 15 years you've got 20 000
horses
dropping dead every day or every year i
should say every year 20 000 horses if
there's
300 000 horses in 15-year lifespan back
in the gangs in new york
days that movie
yeah yeah it's a lot of dead horses and
you need a horse to move the horse
right and they'll probably get pretty
pretty freaked out if they have to move
a dead horse
do you think they know what's going on
yeah i mean it's going to be like
pretty weird no i would imagine am i
dragging this dead
you know horse around and i'm a horse
do you ever stop and think about your
role
in civilization do you ever stop and
think about your role in the culture
because me as a person who never met you
until today
when i think of you you know i've always
thought of you as being this
weirdo super inventor dude who just
somehow or another keeps coming up with
new [ __ ]
but there's not a lot of you out there
like everybody else seems to be
i mean obviously you make a lot of money
and there's a lot of people that make a
lot of money
you like that clock yeah pretty dope
right this is a great clock yeah you
want one i'll get you one sure okay
done i like weird things like this oh
this is the coolest
it's tgt promotion what is this tgt
studios
tgt studios yeah yeah um
it's a gentleman who makes all this by
hand
yeah it's really cool my study is filled
with weird devices
well get ready for another one all right
i'm sending it your way
cool you want a werewolf too i'll hook
you up
all right i'll take one one werewolf and
one clock coming up
do you think about your role in the
culture because me as a person who never
met you
until today i i've always looked at you
and like wow like
how's this guy just keep inventing [ __ ]
like how do you how do you keep coming
up with all these new devices and what
do you ever consider how on you
like i had a dream once that there was a
million teslas instead of like one
tesla there was a million teslas okay
not
chesley the car but nicola oh yeah sure
and that in his day there was a million
people like him
who were radically innovative it was a
weird dream man it was so strange
and i've had it more than once result in
very rapid technology
innovation that's for sure it's one of
the only dreams in my life i've had more
than one time
okay like where i've woken up and it's
in the same dream i'm in the same dream
and in this dream it's 1940s 1950s
but everyone is severely advanced
there's flying
blimps with like lcd screens on the side
of them and everything's bizarre and
strange
and it stuck with me for whatever
obviously this is just a stupid dream
but
for whatever reason all these years that
stuck with me like it takes
one man like nikola tesla
to have more than a hundred inventions
that were patents right
i mean he had some pretty great pretty
[ __ ] amazing
ideas yes but there was in his day there
was very few people like him
that was true what if there was a
million like what
in the end advanced very quickly right
but there's not a million elon musks
there's one [ __ ]
do you think i'm about that please try
to not
hmm
[Laughter]
i don't think i don't think you'd
necessarily want to be me
well what's the worst part about you
people would like it that much
well most people wouldn't but they can't
be you
so that's like that's like some
superhero type [ __ ]
you know you wouldn't want to be
spider-man rather just sleep tight in
gotham city
i hope he's out there doing his job
it's very hard to turn it off yeah
what's the hardest part
it might sound great if it's turned on
but what if it doesn't turn off
now i showed you the isolation tank and
you've never experienced that before
yeah i think that could help you turn it
off a little bit
just for the night yeah just give you a
little bit of sleep
a little bit of perspective magnesium
that you get from the water as well that
makes you
makes you sleep easier because the water
has epsom salts in it
but maybe some sort of strategy for uh
sacrificing your biologi or not
sacrificing but enhancing your
biological recovery time
by figuring out a way whether it's
through meditation or some
other ways to shut off that that thing
at night
like you must have like a constant
stream
of ideas that's running through your
head all the time
you getting text messages from checks no
uh i'm getting text messages from
from friends saying what the hell are
you doing smoking weed
is that bad for you it's legal yeah it's
kind of unapproved
it's not you know uh i'm not a regular
smoker of weed
how often you smoke it almost never
i mean it's it's i don't actually notice
any effect
well there you go there was a time where
i think it was ramdas or someone gave
some buddhist monk a bunch of acid
okay and he ate it and it had no effect
on him
i doubt that i would say that too but
i've never meditated to the level that
some of these people have where they're
constantly meditating all day they don't
have any material possessions
and all of their energy is spent trying
to achieve a certain mindset
i would like to cynically deny that
i'd like to cynically say they just
[ __ ] think the same way i do they
just
hang out with flip-flops on and make
weird noises
but maybe no you know i
i i know a lot of people like weed and
that's fine
uh but i don't find that it is very good
for productivity
for you not for me yeah i mean i would
imagine that for someone like you it's
not someone like you
it would be more like a cup of coffee
right you want
you have a mate yeah it's more like the
opposite of a cup of coffee
like a cup of coffee in reverse oh wheat
is yeah no i'm saying
you would like more more like what would
be beneficial to you would be like
coffee
i like to get things done i like to be
useful
that is one of the hardest things to do
is to be useful
when you say you like to get things done
like in terms of like what
satisfaction when you complete a project
when something something that you
invent comes to fruition and you see
people enjoying it
that feeling yes doing something useful
for other people
that i like doing that's interesting for
other people
yes so that do you think that that is
maybe the way you recognize that you
have this unusual position
in the culture where you can uniquely
influence certain things because of this
i mean you essentially have a gift right
i mean
you would think it was a curse but i'm
sure it's been fueled by
many many years of discipline and
learning but you essentially have a gift
and that you have this radical
sort of creativity engine when it comes
to innovation and technology it's like
you're just you're going at a very high
rpms
all the time what is that doesn't stop
i don't know what would happen if i got
into a sensory deprivation tank
let's try it sounds were concerning
it's like running the engine with no
resistance
that's just is that what it is though
maybe it's not maybe it's fine
i don't know i'll try it i'll try it
have you ever experienced experimented
with meditation or anything
yes what do you do or what have you done
rather
i mean just sort of sit there and be
quiet
and then repeat some mantra
which acts as a focal point
it's distill the mind it distill the
mind
but i don't find myself drawn to it
frequently
do you think that perhaps productivity
is maybe more attractive to you
than enlightenment and like or even the
concept of whatever enlightenment means
like what are you trying to achieve when
you're meditating all the time
with you it seems like almost like
there's a franticness
to your creativity that comes out of
this this burning furnace
and for in order for you to like calm
that thing down
get through you might have to throw too
much water on it
it's like a never-ending explosion
like what is it like i try to explain it
to a dumb person like me
what's going on never-ending explosion
it's just constant ideas
just bouncing around yes
damn yeah so when everybody leaves it's
just elon
sitting at home brushing his teeth just
bunch ideas bouncing around your head
yeah
all the time when did you realize that
that's not the case with most people
i think when i was i don't know five or
six or something i thought i was insane
why did you think you were insane
because it was clear that other people
did not
what their mind wasn't exploding with
ideas all the time
they weren't expressing it they weren't
talking about it all and you realized by
the time you were five or six like oh
they're probably not even getting this
thing that i'm getting
no it was just strange
it was like hmm
i'm strange that was my conclusion
i'm strange but did you feel
diminished by it in any way like knowing
that this is a weird thing that you
really probably couldn't
commiserate with with other people
they wouldn't understand i hope they
wouldn't find out because they might
like put me away with something you
thought that
for a second yes when you were little
yeah i knew they put people away what if
they put me away
like when you were little you thought
this yes wow
like you thought this is so radically
different than the people that are
around me
if they find out i got the stream coming
in
yeah wow
but you know i was only like five or six
so like
do you think this is like i mean there's
there's outliers
biologically you mean there's people
that are seven
foot nine there's people who have giant
hands there's people that have
eyes that are 2015 vision there's always
outliers
um do you feel like you like
caught this like you've got some you're
like on some weird
innovation creativity sort of wave
that's very unusual like you
you tapped into i mean just think of the
the
various things you've been able to
accomplish in a very short amount of
time
and you're constantly doing this that's
a weird you're a weird person
right i agree yeah like what if there's
a million elon musks
well that would be very very weird
yeah it'd be pretty weird like right
real weird definitely
yeah what if they're a million joe
rockets oh there probably is
probably two million
[Laughter]
i mean i think that's the case with a
lot of folks
i mean but like uh you know my goal is
like
try to do useful things
try to maximize it probably the future
is good
um make the future exciting
something you look forward to you know
you know with uh
you know with tesla we're like trying to
make things that people love
you know it's like not i think how many
how many things can you buy that
you really love that really give you joy
so rare so rare i wish there were more
things
that's what we try to do just make
things that somebody loves
when you when you think about making
things that someone loves
like do you specifically think about
like what things would improve
people's experience like what what would
change
the way people interface with life that
would make them
more relaxed or more happy
you really think like when you're
thinking about things like that is that
like one of your considerations like
what
what could i do that would help people
that maybe they wouldn't be able to
figure out
yeah like like what are the set of
things that can be done
to make the future better like
you know like so i think that a future
where we are space faring civilization
and out there among the stars this is
very exciting
this makes me look forward to the future
this makes me want that future
you know the things they need to be
things
that make you look forward to waking up
in the morning you wake up in the
morning
look forward to the day look forward to
the future
in a future where we are space-faring
civilization and out there among the
stars i think that's very exciting
that is a thing we want
whereas if if you knew we would not be a
spacefaring civilization but forever
confined to earth this would not be a
good future that would be very sad
i think it would be so sad future
of the the just the the finite lifespan
of the earth itself and the solar system
itself that even though it's possibly
you know i mean how many
how long do they feel like this sun and
the solar system is going to exist
how many hundreds of millions of years
well it's probably if you're saying the
when does the sun boil the oceans right
about 500 million years so is is it
sad that we never leave because in 500
million years that happens is that what
you're saying
no i just think like if there are two
futurists and one futurist we're out
there among the stars and the things we
read about and
see in science fiction movies the good
ones are true
we have these starships and we're
we we're going to see what other planets
are like and
we're a multi-planet species and the
scope and scale of
consciousness is expanded across
many civilizations and many planets and
many star systems
this is a great future
this is a wonderful thing to me and
that's what we should strive for
hmm but that's biological travel
that's cells traveling physically to
another location
yes do you think that's definitely where
we're going
no yeah i don't think so either i used
to think so
and now i'm thinking more likely less
than ever like almost every day less
likely
we can definitely go to the moon and
mars yeah everything we will go to the
asteroid belt and we can go to the moons
of jupiter
saturn you can even get to pluto that'd
be the craziest place ever if we
colonized mars and re-terraformed it and
turned it into like a big jamaica
just i think i think
turn the whole thing into cancun well
i mean over time it wouldn't be easy but
yes right you could just
you could warm it up yeah you can warm
it up you could add air
you get some water there i mean over
time hundreds of millions of years or
whatever it takes it could be a
multi-planet species
that would be amazing the multi-planet
species that's what's ultimately
like air conditioning saturn i'm
pro-human
me too yeah i love humanity i think it's
great
we're glad as a robot that you love
humans because we we love you too and we
don't want you to kill us and eat us
and uh i mean you know strangely i think
a lot of people don't like humanity and
see it as a blight but i do not
well i think one of those i think part
of that is just they've been
you know they've been struggling when
people struggle they associate their
struggle with other people
they never internalize their problems
they look to other people as holding
them back and people suck and [ __ ]
people
and it's just it you know it's an evil
never-ending cycle
but not always again most people
are really good most people vast
majority
this may sound corny it does sound cool
but love is the answer
it is the answer yep yeah it is
it sounds corny because we're all scared
you know we're all scared of
trying to love people being rejected or
someone taking advantage of you because
you're trying to be loving
sure but if we all could just relax and
love each other
wouldn't hurt to have more love in the
world it definitely wouldn't hurt
yeah it'd be great yeah we should do
that yeah
i agree man really how do you fix that
you have a love machine
[Laughter]
no but uh probably spend more time with
your friends in less time on
social media now deleting social media
from your
applications from your phones and that
give you
uh 10 boost of happiness was what do you
think the percentages
i think probably something like that
yeah good 10
yeah i mean i mean the only thing i've
kept is twitter
because i kind of like need some means
of getting a message out
you know right
[Music]
that's about it
so far so good well what's interesting
with you you actually occasionally
engage with people
on twitter yeah it's
what percentage of that is a good idea
[Laughter]
good question right
it's hard it's mostly i think it's
unbalanced more good than bad
but there's definitely some bad so
do you ever hopefully the good outweighs
the bad do you ever think about how odd
it is the weird feeling that you get
when someone says something shitty to
you on twitter and you read it
the weird feeling this weird little
negative jolt
it's like a subjective negative jolt of
energy that you don't really need to
absorb but you do anyway like well [ __ ]
this guy
[ __ ] him i mean there's a lot of
negativity on twitter
it is but it's a weird it's in in its
form like the way if you ingest it
as if you're like you try to be like a
little scientist as you're ingesting it
you're like well how weird is this and
i'm even getting upset
at some strange person saying something
mean to me
it's not even accurate i mean
the there are a vast number of negative
comments uh
so the vast for the vast majority of i
just ignore them the vast majority
yeah but every now and again you get
drawn in
it's not good it's not good make
mistakes
yes you can make mistakes you can make
some mistakes we're all human
we can make mistakes yeah it's hard
and people love it when you say
something and you take it back they're
like [ __ ] you we saved it forever
[ __ ] screenshot that [ __ ] [ __ ] you
had that thought
you had that thought like well i deleted
it
not good enough you had the thought
i'm better than you i never had that
thought you had that thought you piece
of [ __ ] look i saved it
i put it on my blog yeah i'm not sure
why people think that
that anyone would think that deleting a
tweet makes it go away
it's like hello been the internet for a
while yeah
well it's even like the thing is they
don't want you to be able to delete it
because the problem is if you don't
delete it and you don't believe it
anymore
it's really hard to say hey that thing
above i don't really believe that
anymore
i change the way i the way i view things
yes because people go well [ __ ] you all
right i have that over there i'm gonna
just take that i'm not gonna pay
attention that [ __ ] you wrote
it's on your permanent record it's
forever bro
we'll put this on your permanent record
yeah it's like a tattoo
you keep it oh yeah yeah well it's it's
this thing where there's
it's it's a there's a lack of compassion
it's a lack of compassion issue
people just like intentionally shitty to
each other all the time online and
trying to catch me
it's they're more trying to catch people
doing something that's arrestable like a
cop
trying to like get you know arrests on
his
his record it's like they're trying to
catch you with something more than
they're logically looking at it
thinking it's a bad thing that you've
done or that it's an idea they don't
agree with so much they need to insult
you
trying to catch you yeah i i mean it's
way easier to be mean
on social media than it is to be mean in
person yes
way easier yeah yes it's weird
it's it's not a normal way of human
interacting it's cheating
we're not supposed to be able to
interact so easily but people are not
looking at
yes you would never do that you'd never
be so mean to somebody looking in their
eyes and if you did you'd feel like [ __ ]
most people yeah unless your sociopath
you'd feel terrible
yes
elon musk this has been a pleasure yeah
likewise it really has been it's been
an honor thank you for having me um
thanks for doing this because uh
i know you don't do a lot of uh
long-form stuff like this
i hope i didn't weird you out and i hope
you don't get mad that you smoke weed
i mean not bad it's legal we're in
california this is
just as legal as this whiskey we've been
drinking
exactly this is all good right cheers
thank you um is there any message you
would like to put out other than
love is the answer because i think you
really nailed it with that
no i think you know i think people
should be nicer to each other
and give people and give give more
credit to others
and don't assume that they're mean until
you know they're actually mean
you know just it's easy to demonize
people
you're usually wrong about it people are
nicer than you think
give people more credit i couldn't agree
more
and i want to thank you not just for all
the
crazy innovations you've come up with
and your constant flow of ideas
but that you choose to spread that idea
which is it's uh it's very vulnerable
but it's very honest
and i it resonates with me and i believe
it i believe it's true too
so thank you and all you [ __ ] out
there
be nice be nice [ __ ] all right thank
you everybody thank you very much thank
you good night everybody